du four pour une mise au point au sujet
d'un vote pour chers collègues monsieur
le Président je souhaite procéder à une
rectification de vente concernant Luc
critère 219 de ce jour et en particulier
on l'abandon 9 rectifié terre au
pellergès l'ensemble de mon groupe en
tant de voter pour sauve Madame Nathalie
Goulet qui s'abstient très bien merci
votre mise au point qui figuiera dans
l'analyse politique du scrutin concerné
merci donc nous reprenons la discussion
du projet de loi de finance
rectificative
de la sécurité sociale pour 2023 dans le
Sénat est saisi en application de
l'article 47 céréales
nous en sommes arrivés à l'amendement 83
rectifié au sein de l'article 89 et nous
avons trois et amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion
commune d'abord le 83 rectifié madame la
Présidente
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues la loi Touraine de 2014 a
permis la valorisation des stages dans
la durée de vie au travail et leur
intégration au système des retraites en
ouvrant aux étudiants la possibilité de
demander la prise en compte des périodes
de stage en entreprise dans la limite de
deux trimestres ce dispositif permet aux
assurés de rallonger leur durée
d'assurance et dans certains cas
d'atteindre le taux plein afin
d'améliorer leur niveau de vie à la
retraite et c'est une très bonne chose
ce droit conditionné au versement de
cotisations à un tarif préférentiel
impose toutefois que la demande soit
présentée dans un délai qui ne peut être
supérieur à deux ans après le stage ce
délai particulièrement court explique
pourquoi ce dispositif est très très peu
utilisé les étudiants et les jeunes
actifs à qui il s'adressent non soit pas
connaissance de ce dispositif soit pas
les moyens de racheter ces périodes de
stage aussi cet amendement propose
d'assouplir le dispositif pour permettre
que ces périodes puissent être achetées
jusqu'à un âge qui
ne pourrait cependant pas être inférieur
à 25 ans je vous remercie merci
alamondement 1911 qui le présente il est
défendu monsieur président et un
amendement 3405 madame ponce le présente
il s'agit de l'amendement voilà
identique
la loi du 20 janvier
dans l'avenir du système de retraite a
prévu la possibilité pour les étudiants
de demander leur achat des périodes de
stage en entreprise dans la limite de
deux trimestres ce dispositif fait est
une bonne chose à ces modèles quand même
puisqu'il mais ils permettent de valider
plus facilement la durée d'assurance
requise pour le taux plein et
d'améliorer ainsi indirectement le
niveau de la pension toutefois la
demande de rachat doit aujourd'hui est
effectuée dans un délai de deux ans
maximum après le stage en l'état le
dispositif se heurte donc à deux
problèmes d'une part c'est un dispositif
méconnu la plupart des jeunes qui
cherchent d'abord à s'insérer ignorent
que le dispositif existe et ne s'en
rendent compte que lorsque le délai est
dépassé d'autre part c'est un dispositif
qui s'adresse à de jeunes actifs qui ne
sont pas pleinement en capacité de
racheter ces périodes de stage en début
de carrière
rappelons-le le taux horaire de
gratification est égal au minimum à 4
euros de l'heure les stages
s'accompagnent souvent d'une situation
de précarité puisque les stagiaires
doivent compter la plupart du temps sur
la solidarité familiale voir sur des
emprunts et l'insertion professionnelle
ensuite et parfois difficile lorsqu'il y
a des emprunts par exemple l'ancien
stagiaire est censé racheter ces
trimestres tout en remboursant son
emprunt cette situation ne semble donc
pas adaptée et nous semble qu'il faille
assouplir les conditions d'accès au
rachat de trimestre de stage c'est ce
que le groupe écologiste propose par cet
amendement et nous appelons aussi à ce
que il nous appelons aussi à ce qu'une
information soit faite aux stagiaire via
la convention de stage donc dans la
convention de stage pour lutter contre
le non recours à ce dispositif je vous
remercie alors
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
je suis précédent et nous sommes tout à
fait favorables bien sûr à l'allongement
de ce délai de rachat et merci de nous
préciser un peu vos intentions monsieur
le ministre monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
avis favorable nous sommes dans la même
mécanique pour les amendements examinés
avant le dîner la loi dirait si la maman
est adopté que le
l'âge minimum jusqu'auquel le rachat est
possible est à 25 ans mais l'intention
du gouvernement par décret est plutôt
d'aller jusqu'à 30 ans pour
véritablement tenir compte de la
diversité des parcours bien deux double
à 8 favorable explication de vote je
n'en vois pas ceux qui sont favorables
l'adoption de ces trois amendements
identiques le manifeste en levant la
main
avis contraire abstention merci
un amendement
ensuite deux amendements
identiques
madame poncer mon
mais oui allez-y oui par cet amendement
j'aimerais revenir à cette occasion sur
le mécanisme de la décote la décote a eu
pour conséquence d'augmenter le nombre
de personnes touchées par une des cotes
en même temps que la loi effectivement
était parallèlement aussi une réforme
sur l'âge
vous vous vantez monsieur le ministre de
ne pas déplacer l'âge de la décote 67
ans mais enfin comptiez-vous la portée à
69 ans ça serait quand même difficile
d'autant plus que vous vouliez la mesure
d'âge à 65 donc ça aurait fait prêt on
allait vers 70 ans non ce qu'il fallait
monsieur le ministre c'était soit
supprimé la décote c'est ce que le
groupe écologiste propose mais au moins
quand même la remettre à 65 ans vous
avez des études de l'adresse en 2020
vous avez aussi des études des
départements statistiques qui montrent
comment de réforme en réforme
effectivement le nombre de personnes
touchées par une décote progresse de
trois points pour ce qui est de du
département statistique de trois points
à la CNAV pour la génération par exemple
les femmes vous le savez sont
particulièrement touchées par ce
mécanisme elles sont vous le savez aussi
20% et deux fois plus que les hommes à
devoir attendre 67 ans pour mettre fin à
ce mécanisme la décote souvent on dit
c'est une double peine parce que les
carrières hachées éloignent
effectivement des conditions du taux
plein
je rappelle que des cotes ou pas des
cotes la pension a toujours un
coefficient de progratisation parce que
les personnes croient que c'est la
proratisation qui est annulée donc le
coefficient de proratisation est juste
enfin juste oui à condition que les
minimum soient assez haut mais il est
juste il tient compte effectivement du
prorata de la carrière mais là la décote
c'est un effet démultiplicateur c'est en
cela qu'on parle de double peine en fait
c'est cet effet là qui qui conviendrait
peut-être
d'annuler donc aussi moi je souhaiterais
monsieur le ministre que vous nous
expliquer
enfin parce que vous dites je retape pas
l'âge de la décote enfin moi j'aimerais
dire que de ne pas aggraver une
situation ce n'est pas une mesure
sociale
j'ai connu un syndicaliste qui après
avoir signé un accord comme un très bon
je dirais après
bonsoir monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre mais chers
collègues aujourd'hui les égoutiers ont
le droit à un départ anticipé à 52 ans à
condition d'avoir au moins réalisé 12
années de service dont 6 consécutives
c'est la moindre des choses contenu de
la difficulté de ce métier
je m'excuse de parler de ça à ce moment
là mais les égoutiers ils décrochent à
coup de pelle les graisses de cuisine
accumulées sur les parois
il retire les lingettes qui peuvent
boucher les évacuations il ratissent les
collecteurs pour éviter les
enseignements ils peuvent pas tauger
jusqu'à la taille pour pousser des
wagons remplis de déchets aux
difficultés physiques s'ajoutent des
risques sanitaires ils peuvent trouver
sous terre de l'hydrogène sulfuré qui en
très grande concentration peut s'avérer
mortel les égoutiers sont également
exposés à des particules d'amiante
ces conditions de travail sont pas sans
conséquence j'ai écouté le médecin
Claude d'Anglos qui aujourd'hui
retraitée
qu'est-ce qui nous dit
un écart de 7 ans d'espérance de vie
entre les égoutiers et les ouvriers
je vous le dis avec un peu de solennité
mais quand disait gouttier parle tard la
retraite à 52 ou 54 ans 10 ans à Port 10
ans après 7 ou 8 sont morts
donc je le dis avec
pas polémique mais j'en doute pas que
mes collègues retaillaient au Patriat et
malurai
n'utiliseront pas l'article 38 sur un
sujet d'une telle gravité et je pense
que c'est ça faire offre de
responsabilité et comme ça un sujet où
je pense que c'est bien aussi de prendre
de la hauteur avec la vivacité de nos
débats j'ai choisi aimer ces airs pour
vous dire qu'il faut laisser de
l'espérance aux égoutiers
c'est quoi une vie d'homme ces combats
de l'ombre et de la lumière c'est la
lutte contre l'Espoir elle désespoir
entre la lucidité et la ferveur je suis
du côté de l'espérance mais d'une
espérance conquise lucide et hors de la
naïveté donc vraiment mes chers
collègues maintenant l'origine spéciale
des égoutiers merci de votre attention
je vais demander la vie de la Commission
du gouvernement je me rappelle que je
suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public pour que vous puissiez vous
préparer par le groupe CRCE et nous
allons entendre la vie de la Commission
du gouvernement oui ben écoutez nous
avons dans la réflexion de la commission
considérée qu'effectivement il y avait
un passage
un recul des
âges à la fois pour les sédentaires pour
les actifs pour les super actifs et
effectivement c'est la seule fois un
métier remarquable tout à fait important
il n'empêche que dans la logique qui est
celle de cette loi nous pensons qu'il
est plus raisonnable
d'aller dans ce sens là néanmoins elle
est la durée d'exposition dans ce type
de métier non pas été allongés donc ce
qui est important mais le semble-t-il
c'est qu'on ne les entretiennent pas
dans un dispositif où il reste longtemps
exposé un certain nombre de risques mais
plutôt de trouver à dispositif qui leur
permet une fois passé cette période là
pouvoir rester trouver un métier un peu
moins exposé c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons donné un avis
défavorable
tu es le ministre tu gagnes
c'est le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs jamais vous ne m'entendrez
nier la difficulté la pénibilité
associée au métier des agents des
souterrains égoutiers c'est d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle ils font partie
des catégories dites super actives qui
bénéficient d'un âge de départ anticipé
à 52 ans bientôt 54 ans c'est la raison
pour laquelle dans le cadre de cette
réforme nous avons décidé à la
différence des réformes des retraites
précédentes de laisser inchangé la durée
de service pour pouvoir bénéficier de
cet âge de départ anticipé en
l'occurrence 12 ans de service en tant
que gouttier et 32 ans de service dans
la fonction publique au total
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
facilité les dispositifs pour que ces
agents là puissent un moment donné
changer de métier et nous avons porté
j'ai eu l'occasion de l'exprimer devant
le Sénat une avancée considérable
c'est-à-dire la portabilité complète à
la fois des durées de service mais de
toutes les bonifications associées aux
métiers des catégories actives c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle nous
avons décidé de supprimer la clause
d'achèvement qui imposée aux agents des
catégories actifs de terminer leur
carrière en tant que catégorie active
justement pour nous doter d'outils
d'aménagement de carrière de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse là aussi permettre de
changer de métier et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous devons aussi
travailler non seulement sur des
dispositifs de réparation c'est à dire
partir plutôt à la retraite mais surtout
sur des dispositifs de prévention nous
aurons l'occasion d'en discuter ce sera
à l'article 9 nous allons mettre en
place des fonds de prévention de l'usure
de la pénibilité nous avons des
discussions avec les employeurs
territoriaux puisqu'il s'agit en
l'occurrence d'agent de la fonction
publique territoriale qui vont
exactement dans ce sens là en complément
des mesures de réparation de pouvoir
investir construire des outils
collectifs de prévention de l'usure et
de la pénibilité je crois que c'est
comme ça qu'on répondra réellement aux
agents qui sont sur des métiers les plus
exposés les plus pénibles donc avis est
défavorable pour le gouvernement
également
explication de vote oui madame rossignol
le président en fait j'ai bien écouté le
ministre et au cas où j'aurais eu un
doute sur le fait qu'il fallait voter
ses amendements il a fini de me
convaincre il faut les voter monsieur le
ministre d'abord il y a une petite
musique
j'imagine que c'est des éléments de
langage qui descendent du château jusque
dans les ministères sur les gens doivent
changer de métier l'autre jour j'ai vu
une vidéo du président de la République
au salon de l'agriculture on
l'interrogeait sur le fait de savoir si
une infirmière pouvait aller jusqu'à 64
ans il a répondu mais j'espère que d'ici
là elle aura changé de métier alors deux
choses d'abord des infirmières on en
manque donc c'est pour éviter de changer
de métier ça nous arrangerait bien déjà
et deuxièmement cette idée de du salarié
flexible adaptable qui tout le temps
change de métier quand on change de
start-up qui tout le temps change de
métier comment on change
d'investissement de d'investissement et
quand on change des actions en bourse
mais ça c'est pas ce que les gens
veulent et en plus c'est un mépris pour
le savoir faire des gens pour les
métiers qu'ils ont appris
conscience qui vont vous retiriez ça de
l'esprit parce que c'est pas adapté même
si vous pensez qu'en ce moment ça vous
arrange de dire ça la deuxième chose
c'est que vous opposez fond de
prévention
tout à l'heure notre collègue ça vaut le
délit donner des chiffres moi je les
connaissais pas mais je pense que tout
le monde a dû quand même s'arrêter pour
les écouter sur 10 agents il y en a qui
partent en retraite à 54 ans disant
après il y en a 6 qui sont plus là 7 ou
8 qui sont plus là et fonds de
prévention formidable mais c'est dix ans
avant d'avoir des résultats en matière
de prévention 10 ans alors tous ceux qui
sont déjà en activent aujourd'hui qui
déjà depuis 20-25 ans 30 ans sont
exposés ceux-là ils ont besoin de garder
une retraite jeune maintenant pour
profiter un petit peu de leur retraite
le fonds de prévention c'est pour après
il faut 10 ans pour le fonds de
prévention mais pas votre réforme tout
de suite il y a un pas d'autre demande
si ça vaut le délire
oui c'est le Président mes chers
collègues
je sais pas comment vous dire là mais
utilisons la sagesse quoi
il y aura un aller-retour avec
l'Assemblée nationale
j'ai vraiment c'est des chiffres qui
n'ont rien d'idéologie ou d'étiquettes
etc vous voulez tout à l'heure vous
n'avez pas contesté
mais
enfin quand même avant 65 ans la
surmontalité des égoutiers de 97% mes
collègues la voyez gauche droite il y a
nos éléments de débat il y a
enfin là quand même
d'accord c'est des invisibles
j'ai été comme vous j'ai un parcours
d'élus et tous les travaux
d'assainissement on est dans un
appartement on est là dans un travail
dans le département du Val-de-Marne
privé public d'ailleurs avec l'expertise
privée et la capacité du privé et aussi
du public mais là je suis dire là c'est
ça dépasse l'entendement
c'est un régime spécial qui mérite
d'être maintenu et et et faites ça après
on peut toujours discuter avoir des
allers-retours de discussion etc j'ai
bien entendu puis après monsieur le
ministre dans le prolongement de ce que
dit ma collègue Rossignol changer de
métier moi vous savez
je vais pas me fabriquer une histoire
que je n'ai pas mais j'ai l'occasion de
rencontrer énormément de gens et des
métiers extraordinaires dans la fonction
publique vous savez il y a des femmes et
des hommes qui aiment leur métier
ils aiment leur métier ils ont pas envie
d'en changer et dans les équipes avec
lesquelles ils travaillent ils ont
rencontré des gens formidables ils ont
rencontré de l'humanité la socialisation
c'est pas à eux de changer c'est à nous
de créer des conditions qu'ils ont un
minimum d'épanouissement voilà donc
franchement sagesse et si on pouvait se
rassembler sur ces amendements je pense
que personne n'y perd son identité voilà
merci de votre attention
je suis le ministre et merci monsieur le
Président je reprends la parole parce
que je pense que c'est un débat
important et je suis heureux qu'on
puisse la voir puisqu'on je l'ai dit on
avait peu parlé des métiers de la
fonction publique et il y a des éléments
que vous venez de d'exprimer sur lequel
on peut se retrouver évidemment moi je
passe ma journée à essayer de réfléchir
à améliorer la situation des agents de
la fonction publique et bien sûr qu'il y
a beaucoup d'agents de la fonction
publique qui sont extraordinairement
attachés leur métier et qui aiment ce
qu'ils font parce que ça a du sens parce
qu'ils servent l'intérêt général et donc
bien sûr que nous devons penser à la
fois les mécanismes de réparation et les
mécanismes d'adaptation et en ça nous
avons une différence fondamentale vous
opposez l'un à l'autre et d'ailleurs vos
interventions sont quelque peu
contradictoires je veux faire deux trois
remarques la première
vous dites ils ne veulent pas changer de
métier mais dans ce cas là c'est déjà
comme ça que le mécanisme sur lequel
repose les bénéfices la catégorie Super
Active sont déjà construits puisque je
vous l'ai dit 12 ans de service en tant
qu'égoutier 32 ans de service dans la
fonction publique c'est donc déjà qu'on
avait intégré la possibilité que
l'exposition à la pénibilité de ce
métier en particulier ces 12 ans c'est à
dire une durée de service qui est plus
courte que les 17 ans ou 27 ans de durer
de service qui sont associés aux autres
métiers de la fonction publique donc
c'est déjà comme ça que le système a été
construit justement pour permettre de
changer de métier et au fond quelles
sont les trois questions qu'on doit se
poser face aux métiers qui ont une
réelle pénibilité est-ce que je peux
aménager mon temps de travail
est-ce que je peux aménager mon poste de
travail c'est à dire améliorer les
conditions est-ce que je peux changer de
métier et à ces trois questions là nous
apportons des réponses dans le projet de
loi est-ce que je peux aménager mon
temps de travail nous aurons en discuté
c'est l'introduction pour la fonction
publique de ce qui n'existait pas avant
c'est-à-dire de la retraite progressive
nous aurons l'occasion d'avoir là aussi
le débat c'est à dire la possibilité de
se mettre à temps partiel sur la fin de
sa carrière est-ce que je peux aménager
mon poste de travail c'est la question
de la prévention et je ne veux pas
l'opposer à la question de la réparation
moi je ne baisse pas les bras vous savez
aujourd'hui dans la fonction publique
territoriale il y a au sein de la cnrsl
un Fond national de prévention vous
savez combien il y a d'argent sur ce
fond 15 millions d'euros vous savez quel
est le montant utilisé chaque année pour
la prévention 5 millions d'euros ce fond
est totalement sous-utilisé c'est à dire
que ensemble collectivement la
révolution culturelle aussi managériale
que nous avons à faire c'est de beaucoup
plus investir sur l'adaptation des
métiers et la prévention et je ne veux
pas l'opposer alors oui le mot
manageuriel je vois vous fait réagir
mais je l'assume je pense que
l'attention managériale c'est
l'attention porter aussi à pouvoir
adapter les postes et ensuite est-ce que
l'on peut changer le métier oui il y a
des parcours à proposer où on doit
effectivement donner la possibilité aux
agents publics qui le souhaitent de se
former aujourd'hui on le fait pas
suffisamment pour pouvoir changer de
métier et précisément avec ces fonds de
prévention on pourra aussi financer les
formations pour que les agents puissent
changer de métier vous voyez il y a pas
de fatalité moi je ne partage pas nous
avons une différence fondamentale vous
dites deux ans de travail de plus et
deux ans de prison ferme vous le dites
parfois et bien c'est pas la vision
c'est pas la vision que j'ai c'est pas
la vision que j'ai je ne nie pas la
pénibilité des métiers mais on doit être
capable effectivement d'apporter des
solutions concrètement là maintenant
merci monsieur le Président rénal
s'il vous plaît
ministre a répondu
aussi sensible à ça monsieur le
Président oui
[Musique]
c'est le président sur les ministres
sincèrement monsieur le ministre c'est
moyennement convaincant votre affaire
alors
non il y a toujours il y a toujours des
éléments qui sont juste dans un propos
il y a toujours du juste du moins juste
il y a une partie qu'on comprend ce
qu'on voit pas c'est la gestion la
gestion des délais monsieur le ministre
si vous avez une seconde pour m'écouter
non il l'a pas
tarder ça j'attends un peu bon et ça va
venir voilà merci merci donc la question
c'est pas d'avoir le discours
entrepreneurial
une vision positive de la fonction
publique qui se mobilise qui change etc
tout ça on entend ces éléments on a été
nombreux et Lulu locaux et dans les
communes aussi il faut mobiliser motiver
changer etc oui on connaît ce discours
non là le problème c'est la différence
entre le temps du discours et de la mise
en pratique et la réalité d'aujourd'hui
parce que la réalité d'aujourd'hui elle
est que tout de suite il y a deux ans de
plus pour les gens qui sont voilà c'est
ça le truc et que les mesures dont vous
parlez si
tenter qu'elle se mette en œuvre elles
vont mettre 10 ans 15 ans un truc donc
en attendant vous résolvez rien et les
chiffres qui vous ont été présentés
continueront et ça je pense qu'il faut
qu'on l'est en tête et qu'on trouve des
solutions de court terme c'est pour ça
que ces amendements bien sûr nous les
voterons
rapidement de Monsieur Raynal sur le
temps parce que la réalité c'est que les
gens n'ont qu'une vie
leur dire dans 10 ans
on aura fait mieux la prévention les
métiers auront évolué ont réussira à
faire des mutations d'emplois et à ce
moment-là en effet pourquoi pas repenser
la durée de départ à la retraite sauf
que veut c'est ici et maintenant
et même avec votre prévention avec la
meilleure volonté du monde
vous n'allez pas rapidement permettre un
de prévenir de organiser la mutation de
ceux qui sont maintenant dans ce métier
depuis longtemps
puisque vous nous annoncez une loi
travail
j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion de
discuter
de comment le système a tellement parlé
les tâches
a tellement moins considéré le
travailleur comme acteur d'une
collectivité qui est l'entreprise mais
comme celui qui doit faire une tâche à
l'instant T quasiment interchangeable
puisque précaire puisque sous-traitant
puisque machin
or toutes les logiques de promotion
sociale dans l'emploi on la plupart du
temps dans l'histoire était lié à la
continuité dans la même entreprise ou
dans la même branche de salariés qui
dans des équipes faisaient de la
formation continue etc on a tué ça parce
que maintenant chacun dans sa tâche et
comme il faut avoir un autre boulot que
dès qu'on a fini et autres donc moi ce
que je vais vous dire c'est que vous
allez dire à tous ces gens là maintenant
tu dois te former parce que tu n'es plus
apte tu dois travailler plus longtemps
et tu seras pas apte à le faire
et ben je vais vous dire un truc on
forme jamais bien les gens en leur
disant tu vas travailler plus comme tu
auras du mal à suivre il faut que tu te
forme ça marchera pas donc moi je pense
que la première des choses c'est d'abord
de maintenir le système actuel il ne
doivent pas partir en retraite au-delà
des des
âges actuels et en effectivement on aura
l'occasion de discuter sur l'évolution
du travail de la formation continue etc
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres mes chers collègues mon
collègue Pascal ça vole Delhi défense
cet amendement avec passion on l'a vu
même émotion parce que comme un certain
nombre d'entre nous il rencontre un
certain nombre de travailleurs et
travailleurs qui font les métiers utiles
et essentiels mais les égoutiers c'est
aussi spécifique très spécifique et
Pascal l'a rappelé c'est notamment une
espérance de vie
de 17 ans dégradé
par rapport à un cadre et 10 ans par
rapport à un ouvrier il faut qu'on
entende ça moi je partage pas par
exemple qu'on est supprimé les régimes
spéciaux pour les gaziers électriciens
je vois pas un gazier électricien monter
un pylône pour nous remettre
l'électricité un 31 décembre en plein
froid j'espère que il aura pas 63 ans et
9 mois mais peu importe je reviens sur
les égoutiers quand vous nous répondez
monsieur le ministre de choses la
première année gouttière il finit donc
sa carrière aujourd'hui à 52 ans vous
dites la fin de sa vie peut se mettre en
temps partiel
45-50 ans c'est en plein moment d'abord
c'est pas connaître la situation de
l'assainissement mais y compris ça veut
dire être en situation d'être chef de
famille et de devoir se mettre en temps
partiel et donc d'avoir un salaire
dégradé et je crois que personne ne veut
ça et la deuxième chose lorsque vous
nous dites bon ben on peut changer dans
sa vie oui bien sûr nous on y croit la
formation tout au long de sa vie sauf
que franchement qu'on a égouttier qu'on
a des horaires décalés des horaires de
nuit un métier pénible est-ce que vous
croyez certes sincèrement que le soir
arrive et on y tiens allez je vais
bosser je vais passer un concours pour
reprendre un autre boulot dans la
fonction publique cadre C personne quoi
ça personne ne peut croire ça on est usé
par la vie voilà et donc ça ça
fonctionne sur le papier c'est très beau
mais dans le réel ça ne marche pas et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on vous demande
les égoutiers de faire un geste je vous
remercie bien je vais maintenant
consulter si je leur
ai ajouté quelque chose oui oui
de prendre la parole mais je voulais
quand même rajouter quelque chose par
rapport aux conditions de travail dans
la fonction publique parce que j'ai
quelque peu travaillé sur le sujet dans
notamment dans la loi transformation de
la fonction publique et nous avons quand
même mis en place deux mesures qui
peuvent peut-être permettre à ces
personnes là de ne pas être usées
complètement
au bout de leur carrière parce qu'il y a
un entretien à mi-carrière qui est prévu
justement pour ces métiers difficiles
pour voir avec leur employeur ce qui a
moyen de faire pour éviter d'aller
jusqu'au bout de la pénibilité et
envisager un reclassement et ensuite il
y a une deuxième mesure qui s'appelle le
droit à la période de préparation au
classement justement pour ces personnes
qui arriveraient à une pénibilité telle
qu'il faudrait qu'il change et qui
disait une période de préparation voilà
c'est quand même des mesures
intéressantes pour éviter l'usure
professionnelle bien je vais consulter
le scrutin public il va être le scrutin
est donc ouvert
trouver
la peinture
je suis là
résultat du scrutin
345 votants
342 exprimés pour 101 contre 241 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous allons appeler l'abonnement 42 93
madame gréaume le présente si je peux me
permettre monsieur le Président je vais
défendre le
4287 en même temps très bien très bien
alors monsieur le ministre vous entendez
faire travailler tous les Français et
Françaises plus longtemps et surtout en
faisant mine de leur accorder plus nous
voulons vous interpeller sur le passage
supprimer de cet article L12 la petite
disparue qui nous inquiète et je cite le
maximum de bonification et donner aux
militaires qui quittent le service à 59
ans cette phrase là elle a disparu dites
moi monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
nous aider à y voir plus clair les
militaires qui quittent le service à 59
ans
bénéficieront-ils toujours du maximum de
bonification
nous pensons que les carrières des
militaires sont d'une pénibilité
particulièrement intense engageant le
corps du travailleur ou de la
travailleuse vers son sacrifice
envisageable pour la nation avec des
conditions de travail physique
éprouvante qui méritent et au-delà qui
nécessite pour leur bien et la sûreté de
notre armée un âge de départ adapté et
une botteification conséquente donc le
présente un moment vise à refuser la
limitation du cumul des bonifications à
hauteur de 20 trimestre ainsi que la
suppression du maximum de modifications
pour les militaires quittant le service
à 59 ans et le deuxième amendement est
un amendement de repli pour maintenir le
système de bonification maximum pour
tous les militaires qui quittent le
service à 59 ans merci alors la vie de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
effectivement je comprends bien le souci
l'objet de cet amendement mais je crois
que en supprimant ces articles là
ces alinéas pardon ça contre indique le
résultat que vous souhaitez escompter
voyez-vous et en conséquence nous
donnons un avis défavorable alors c'est
sûr que les bonifications qu'elles
soient du cinquième pour les militaires
ou du 10e par exemple pour les
aides-soignantes ont un cumul on les
limites à 5 en général pourquoi pourquoi
il y a cumule c'est parce que on ne
souhaite pas que ces personnes-là qui
sont plus exposées de que d'autres
restent trop longtemps dans le
dispositif si vous voulez parce que
sinon le dispositif permettant notamment
de partir plus tôt on peut penser
qu'elles vont rester dans le métier
surtout elles aiment ce métier mais on
les laisse dans un métier plus exposé et
finalement leur enfance service c'est la
raison pour laquelle il semble plus
judicieux de limiter le dispositif de
ces bonifications en tout non pas le
dispositif la limite de ces
bonifications et je crois que c'est pas
tout à fait ce que vous souhaitez donc
avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre même avec le
rapport mais ma vie je suis saisie d'une
demande de scrutin public sur cette
amendement pour que vous puissiez vous
préparer par l'explication de vote le
scrutin public est ouvert
ça ne demande à voter
attendez
337 exprimés pour 93 contre 244 le Sénat
n'a pas adopté
alors nous allons
sur
deux amendements
je suis bien sur l'amendement 4294 c'est
bien ça c'est un moment de repli qui
vise à supprimer le plafonnement de
cumul de l'ensemble des bonifications à
20 trimestre
et je rappelle encore une fois les
militaires vont on en a besoin certes et
on en aura besoin encore plus bientôt et
je pense que
ce n'est pas un bon coup qu'on leur fait
avis de la commission
de vote je n'envoie pas
ceux qui sont favorables je suis une
saisie une demande de scrutin public
où il est ouvert
exprimer 332 pour
81 contre 251 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
et nous passons à l'amendement
4294 qui le présente
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je pense qu'il
serait important de parler un petit peu
sur le fond des problèmes d'attractivité
des métiers de la fonction publique nous
sommes tous confrontés dans nos
collectivités
particulièrement dans dans la mienne les
Hauts-de-Seine sur les problèmes
d'embauche les collectivités ne peuvent
plus embaucher notamment dans l'Aide
sociale à l'enfance il y a une perte
d'attractivité très forte de tous les
métiers de la santé de la police de
l'enseignement qui est général qui est
dû à une perte de pouvoir d'achat très
forte depuis une vingtaine d'années qui
a été un peu compensée avec
l'augmentation du point indice mais qui
reste très très forte la question de
fond que nous pourrions nous poser ici
c'est en quoi le la retraite et le rôle
de la retraite peut être constitutif
d'une meilleure attraction du meilleur
attractivité des emplois de la fonction
publique c'est vraiment un débat de fond
monsieur le ministre ce que l'équidé je
je vous le redis elles sont confrontées
aujourd'hui à un problème d'embauche qui
est vraiment diriment et dont il faut
s'occuper merci monsieur le Président
alors l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
suppression d'aller à d'alinéa les uns
après les autres donc avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie
alors je suis saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public donc si vous voulez bien
vous préparer pas de demande
d'explication de vote le scrutin est
ouvert
345 votes 344 exprimés 93 cours contre
251 et nous passions numéro
rectifié biche madame gréaume le
présente
le gouvernement
s'imagine sûrement pouvoir limiter la
colère qui gronde dans le pays en
épargnant certains régimes spéciaux de
ce projet de réforme à populaire dans
cette logique et vous prétendez prendre
en compte des spécificités pour les
policiers pour pieds surveillants ou
encore pénitentiaire ou encore les
militaires pourtant vous leur demandez
tout de même je cite de participer à
l'effort collectif j'aimerais comprendre
d'ailleurs ce qu'il y a de collectif
dans un système où seuls les
travailleurs sont à contribution quand
dans le même temps le capital et la
fortune des ultra-riches prospère sans
que vous ne leur demandez rien ce
printemps du effort collectif notre
personne monsieur le ministre pas plus
que les postures en demi teinte quand on
regarde ce que réserve votre projet de
réforme aux militaire on voit bien que
vous n'êtes que dans les éléments de
langage les efforts que vous allez leur
demander ces deux ans de plus
concrètement c'est cela que vous ne
dites pas
car pour elle et pour celles et ceux
dont la limite d'âge est supérieure ou
égale à 57 ans vous allez décaler de
deux ans l'application de l'âge de
l'application de la décote dite carrière
longue si les militaires comme sur les
travailleurs et travailleurs votre
projet n'a qu'un seul objectif réaliser
des économies sur le dos de celles et
ceux qui se sont épuisés par une vie de
labeur par une vie de service à la
nation pourtant les spécificités du
régime des militaires tiennent à
plusieurs points essentiels monsieur le
ministre et parmi ces derniers on trouve
l'importance de manifester la
reconnaissance de la Nation à ces hommes
et ces femmes qui l'ont servi en
intégrant les corps de l'armée parce que
nous estimons que cette reconnaissance
est un devoir de l'État nous vous
demandons par cet amendement de ne pas
décaler l'application de la décote 10
carrière longue merci monsieur le
rapporteur
avis défavorable sur le ministre
oui madame la sénatrice vous me parlez
d'éléments de langage mais si vous me le
permettez je vous le dis très
respectueusement il me semble que c'est
plutôt vous qui venait de déployer des
éléments de langage avec un discours
très généraliste et un amendement qui me
semble totalement à côté de la plaque de
ce qui est le système de bonification
pour les militaires parce que votre
amendement il vise à supprimer l'âge
d'annulation de la décote c'est-à-dire
faire perdre tout le droit justement de
bénéfice pour les militaires je vais
ajouter un deuxième élément les
militaires leur départ avancer à la
retraite il repose sur une durée de
service et non pas contrairement à
d'autres métiers de la fonction publique
sur un âge d'ouverture des droits et
comme ce que nous faisons dans le cadre
de cette réforme c'est de modifier l'âge
d'ouverture des droits mais de laisser
inchangé et la durée de service et l'âge
d'annulation de la décote en
l'occurrence c'est là où vous tombez
complètement à côté de la plaque ça n'a
pas de conséquences justement pour les
militaires donc la meilleure manière je
crois de leur rendre honneur et il faut
le faire pour le l'engagement qui est le
leur c'est d'être précis et pointu cet
amendement retirait des droits je crois
aux militaires et donc je vous invite à
le retirer
alors je vais le retirer monsieur le
ministre mais simplement j'aurais bien
aimé que vous m'expliquez l'amendement
avant parce que sur les bonifications
vous avez pas expliqué correctement pour
vous avez juste dit contre et vous
n'avez pas dit pourquoi cette phrase
n'apparaît plus dans la loi et je vais
en profiter monsieur le Président
pour le suivant non pour le suivant je
le je il y a des fendu il est défendu la
vie de la Commission
toujours la même affaire donc avis
défavorable c'est le Ministre ce serait
identique
je suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public
scrutin ouvert
345 exprimé 344 pour
93 contre 251 il n'est pas adopté et
nous passons à l'avantement 4300 deux
madame Brulat il est rectifié bis
avec la parole
merci monsieur
que nous évoquons depuis quelques temps
désormais s'appliquera on l'a en partie
évoqué à l'instant aux fonctionnaires
qui appartiennent aux catégories dites
actives et super active des catégories
qui s'appliquent aux seules agents de la
fonction publique exerçant des missions
qui représentent un risque particulier
ou des fatigue exceptionnelles afin de
bénéficier d'un départ en retraite
anticipée ces emplois publics concernent
par exemple et tout particulièrement les
agents de la pénitentiaire les agents de
la fonction publique hospitalière les
agents de police ou encore les
sapeurs-pompiers l'allongement de leur
carrière à deux années supplémentaires
représentent un recul social extrêmement
important pour des professions qui sont
pourtant unanimement reconnus comme
particulièrement difficiles et
entraînant une fatigue fatigue accrue
justifiant pleinement ces départs
anticipés avec cette réforme certes ces
agents c'est l'argument dont vous usez
et AB pourrait partir en retraite plus
tôt que les autres fonctionnaires
n'apportent en pas à ces cas à ces
catégories dites actives ou super actif
mais ils devront quand même travailler
deux années de plus à des tâches
particulièrement pénibles et usantes
après une carrière déjà bien longue
ajoutant que ces métiers font aussi
l'objectif sont aussi l'objet pardon de
fatigue qu'on pourrait qualifier de
morale de psychologie au quotidien la
violence le travail avec des usagers en
très grande souffrance qui justifie à
nos yeux un repas un départ moins tardif
on parle là de 700 000 personnes qui
seront touchées par cette mesure injuste
si elle était adoptée en l'état et je
crois que c'est un nouveau coup dur qui
succède à celui qui leur a déjà été
porté avec la réforme de 2011 la réforme
verte qui avait déjà décalé leur départ
en retraite anticipée pour les
catégories du super actives l'âge de
départ légal devrait
un autre avis ne pas être repoussé car
la pénibilité de leur mission ne faiblit
pas avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
effectivement le choix a été fait de
reporter l'effort collectif sur toutes
les professions et si on ne fait que
effectivement des différences les uns
par rapport aux autres on continue à
avoir des statuts différents vous êtes
dans le privé vous êtes dans le public
vous faites le même métier vous n'êtes
pas traité différemment vous êtes dans
un régime spécial c'est encore différent
c'est pas la même prise en compte de la
pénibilité ni de l'aptitude ni des
facteurs d'usure professionnelle c'est
la raison pour laquelle compte tenu que
on demande à tout le monde de faire en
sorte de travailler plus plus il y a de
personnes qui sont qui sortent de ce
dispositif plus l'effort collectif
reporte sur quelques-uns c'est pas le
choix que nous avons fait donc avis
défavorable défavorable que le
rapporteur
je suis soumis d'une demande de scrutin
public je vais explication de vote
madame Linde
chers rapporteur je suis très je partage
votre idée quand il y a un effort à
faire faudrait qu'il soit équitablement
réparti ou au moins également répartis
ce qui est pas tout à fait la même chose
sauf que avec la réforme de la retraite
de telle que vous l'engagez
toutes les prévisions ont montré
qu'en 2030
la le salaire moyen de la fonction dans
le privé aura augmenté de 12 à 14%, et
comme vous vous êtes engagé dans vos
simulations à ne pas augmenter la
participation de l'État la simulation
fait
référence à une baisse de pouvoir
d'achat de 8 % des agents de la fonction
publique alors vous pouvez pas nous dire
on demande l'effort tout le monde doit
avoir la même chose puis au bout du
compte les salariés du privé en moyenne
parce qu'évidemment en moyenne ça va pas
être la même chose pour tout le monde
vont augmenter pendant que ceux du privé
vont baisser et ça c'est dans le rapport
du corps
qu'est-ce qu'il dit
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre moi je répondrai au
rapporteur bien sûr vous êtes un peu
d'autres crinière sur la base sur la
méthode tout le monde aligné au même
tarif et deux ans de plus pour tout le
monde on joue sur la je dirais sur deux
ans qu'on confie ce que au à nos
concitoyens certains et ceux qui ont été
cités par notre collègue là rendre
service des services énormes et souvent
en période de crise on les met en valeur
et là finalement en les condamne au même
sort que les autres alors que ils ont
accompli des missions qui les ont usées
qui les ont fatigué mais je sais vous
allez leur parler des écoutiers nous
reparler même tarif pour tous les
métiers insaluent eux on fait des
métiers difficiles que peu de nos
concitoyens ont fait donc nous voterons
l'amendement
monsieur le ministre
juste un mot puisque vous réagissez je
n'allonge pas la durée des débats j'ai
déjà rappelé ici les avancées que nous
apportons pour les agents les 700 000
agents des catégories actives
portabilité des droits suppression des
dégressivité des bonifications
suppression de la clause d'achèvement je
pense que elles sont nombreuses
effectivement pour renforcer les droits
de ces métiers je veux juste apporter
une information aujourd'hui l'âge
effectif l'âge effectivement pas l'âge
d'ouverture des droits mais là j'ai
effectivement de départ à la retraite
des catégories actives c'est déjà l'âge
d'ouverture des droits plus deux ans
donc les agents publics en l'occurrence
n'ont pas attendu ce débat là pour
partir un peu plus tard que l'âge
d'ouverture des droits qu'il aurait
accordé
oui je suis désolé de reprendre la
parole mais enfin il faut dans ce cas-là
il faut pas il faut pas que le ministre
reparle non plus
effectivement quand on part quand on
liquide ses droits il y a toujours deux
facteurs qu'on comprend en compte on
prend en compte la possibilité là je
légale d'ouverture des droits à la
retraite et on prend en compte les faits
enfin la décote donc j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure qui sont qui a un effet
multiplicateur des carrières incomplètes
et c'est pareil effectivement pour les
catégories actives
d'ailleurs je remarque que vous défendez
la les catégories actives c'est
formidable parce que vous avez toujours
dit que le la prise en compte de la
pénibilité ne devait pas conduire à
recréer les catégories actives donc
où les régimes spéciaux vous préférez
une prise en compte individuelle et non
collective des métiers donc
effectivement il y a il y a cet effet
mais je rappelle parce que je l'ai déjà
dit que c'est pas parce que l'âge
conjoncturel de départ à la retraite est
supérieure à l'âge que vous pouvez dire
que le décalage de l'âge n'a pas d'effet
puisqu'on est sur des moyennes et tous
ceux je suis désolé il y a une partie
quand même importante qui part sur le
critère de l'âge légal c'est-à-dire ils
acceptent ils consentent enfin consente
à la décote et j'ai pu les chiffres mais
c'est de l'ordre de 20% et c'est 20% là
vous voyez vous les obligez
là à deux enfermes donc il y a toujours
deux mécanismes mais les raisonnements
par moyens sont un vraiment un biais un
biais de raisonnement
nous allons maintenant voter j'aurai
simplement dire que quand les ministres
n'interviennent pas vous le reprochez et
quand les ministres éclaire le débat et
bien vous leur reprochez aussi je
voudrais le rappeler quand même c'est me
semble-t-il important pour la qualité de
nos débats donc le scrutin est ouvert
est-ce que quelqu'un demande encore à
voter NON
345 votants 345 exprimés 93 pour contre
252 le Sénat n'a pas adopté mais nous
passons à
rectifiés qui le présente
il est défendu il n'est pas défendu
madame lui va
pardon monsieur le président
le recul de de deux ans de l'âge de la
retraite s'appliquera également au
fonctionnaires appartenant aux
catégories dites actives et super active
pour rappel ces deux catégories existent
depuis 1949 et nécessite 17 à 20 ans de
service pour que certains fonctionnaires
puissent en bénéficier ces catégories ne
s'appliquent qu'aux seuls agents de la
fonction publique exercent des missions
qui présentent un risque particulier où
les fatigue exceptionnelles afin de
bénéficier d'un départ en retraite
anticipé ces emplois public concernent
particulièrement les agents de la
pénitentiaire les agents de la fonction
publique hospitalière les agents de
police ou encore les sapeurs-pompiers
l'allongement de leur carrière de deux
années supplémentaires constituent un
recul social pour ces femmes et ces
hommes dans les métiers sont unanimement
reconnus comme particulièrement
difficile et entraîne une fatigue accrue
justifiant pleinement un départ anticipé
avec cette réforme certes ces agents
pourraient partir en retraite plutôt que
les autres fonctionnaires n'appartenant
pas aux catégories directives ou super
active mais ils devront tout de même
travailler deux années de plus à des
tâches pénible et usantes avec une
carrière déjà bien longue ainsi ce sont
700 000 personnes qui seront touchées
par cette mesure injuste si elle était
adoptée en l'état c'est un nouveau coup
dur porté assez fonctionnaires après
celui de 2011 et la réforme verte qui a
décalé l'âge de départ en retraite
anticipée de 55 à 57 ans pour les
catégories dites super actives l'âge de
départ légal sera repoussée de 50 à 52
ans alors que la pénibilité de leur
mission ne faiblit pas c'est pourquoi
nous demandons la suppression de
cette alors l'avis de la commission
Monique Lubin vous nous avez habitué à
travailler correctement vos amendements
ça fait 10 amendements que l'on présente
de suppression et la moitié 2
aboutissent à l'inverse de ce que vous
souhaitez il n'y a pas eu de
modification des dispositions pour la
durée de
maintien en service de service elle est
restée malgré les augmentations d'âge
elle est restée au même nombre d'années
en conséquence vous demandez de faire
disparaître ces dispositions vous ne
souhaitez pas quand même qui travaille
plus longtemps dans ce type d'activité
donc je pense qu'il est plus raisonnable
de retirer cet amendement
il est maintenu
il est maintenu donc on a un double avis
défavorable monsieur gilet voulait
expliquer votre vote pour éclairer
l'assemblée ainsi que Monsieur Carouge
comprends monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur vous apportez des éléments
j'ai un peu de difficultés à pouvoir
véritablement les vérifier sur le fond
mais je voudrais souligner deux aspects
le premier aspect c'est qu'en fait le
référentiel de ce projet de loi il est
assis une réalité de la société de la
fin des années 90 et quand on regarde
d'un peu plus près pour se rapporter à
ces catégories actives et super active
elle concerne les agents notamment de la
pénitentiaire les agents de la fonction
publique hospitalière les agents de
police ou encore par exemple les
sapeurs-pompiers et regardez la réalité
des sapeurs-pompiers aujourd'hui dans la
réalité de la société des années 2020
moi je suis sénateur de la Gironde j'ai
vécu donc les feux hors normes que vous
avez tous connus récemment mais la
réalité de ces métiers aujourd'hui ce
sont des métiers qui de toute manière
seront de plus en plus exposées ils
seront de plus en plus exposés et
aujourd'hui et bien le projet de loi
apparemment leur demanderait de
travailler donc deux années
supplémentaires donc comment peut-on
accepter ce type de proposition c'est en
dehors véritablement des réalités des
métiers au regard des enjeux notamment
climatiques que notre pays va subir et
pas uniquement climatique bien sûr quand
on regarde des problématiques de la
santé et du secteur de la santé il
faudra encore de nombreuses années pour
arriver à créer des conditions de
travail qui soient réellement
satisfaisantes et qui rééquilibre un
moment donné le métier dans l'ensemble
de ses choix donc véritablement
supprimer effectivement ou allonger de
deux ans c'est particulièrement
inacceptable
sur le président monsieur le ministre
tout à l'heure le rapporteur
a dit quelque chose qui est
éminemment faux vous avez dit notre
choix c'est de faire en sorte que on
allonge de manière globale l'âge de la
retraite et qu'on demande le même effort
à tout le monde et on est là au cœur au
cœur d'un des problèmes fondamentaux de
cette de cette réforme parce que
justement ce qui compte et c'est ce
qu'on apprend en général aux étudiants
en première année c'est pas la moyenne
c'est l'écart à la moyenne et vous
faites comme si vous faites comme si
passez de 62 à 64 ans
ça faisait la même chose pour tout le
monde on sait très bien que l'espérance
de vie et l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé et corrélée à deux choses d'abord
aux revenus d'une part et d'autre part à
la CSP et vous nous expliquez très
gentiment que les conséquences sont les
mêmes pour chacun c'est faux
fondamentalement faux et de fait la
réforme sera inégale et concernera plus
certains que d'autres par ailleurs ne
pas tenir en compte la spécificité de
certaines fonctions qu'on encens par
ailleurs comme celle de pompiers dont on
a encore eu besoin c'est relativement
particulier mais au-delà de ça c'est
l'erreur de raisonnement sur lequel
repose cette réforme c'est de faire
comme si nous étions tous pareils alors
que nous sommes fondamentalement tous
différents et dans des situations
sociales qui sont nettement marquées et
nettement différenciées si je vais
consulter ceux qui sont favorables à son
amendement
à cet abonnement de manifestant devant
la main
avis contraire
abstention il n'est pas adopté et nous
allons passer l'amendement
merci monsieur le Président notre
amendement porte sur les catégories
actives et super active de
fonctionnaires pour rappel c'est deux
catégories existent depuis 1949 et
nécessite 17 à 20 ans de service pour
que certains fonctionnaires puissent en
bénéficier c'est catégories s'appliquent
aux seules agents de la fonction
publique exerçant des missions qui
présentent un risque particulier ou des
fatigue exceptionnelles afin de
bénéficier donc d'un repas d'un départ
excusez-moi anticipé ces emplois public
concernent particulièrement les agents
de la pénitentiaire les agents de la
fonction publique hospitalière les
agents de police ou encore les
sapeurs-pompiers agent des dépôts
mortuaires agent d'entretien des
usines d'incinération des ordures
ménagères ménagères
pompier professionnel agent des services
de désinfection fossoyeur blanchisseur
et blanchisseuses des hôpitaux avec
cette réforme il et elle verront leur
âge légal de départ reculé de deux ans
pour atteindre 59 ans quand on personnel
actif de la police nationale au
personnel de surveillance de
l'administration pénitentiaire aux
agents des réseaux souterrains des
égouts encore aux agents du corps des
identificateurs de l'institut
médico-légal de la préfecture de police
de Paris le recul de l'âge de départ
sera repoussé à 64 ans franchement ce
n'est pas acceptable mais même là tout à
l'heure Pascal ça voldemi vous a pris un
exemple celui des égoutiers j'en ai cité
d'autres il a essayé de vous faire
réagir au-delà de ce que nous sommes et
les uns et les autres dans cette
hémicycle et puis évidemment et bien
rien vous vous obstinez vous continuez
et on vit franchement je pense parfois
dans deux mondes parallèles alors l'avis
de la commission monsieur
la vie monsieur le Président mais ma vie
qu'auparavant une ministre oui en
l'occurrence madame la sénatrice vous
conclu en disant qu'on vit dans le monde
parallèle moi je vis dans le monde réel
des fonctionnaires et des agents publics
et en l'occurrence des agents publics
contractuels puisque l'amendement que
vous proposez il supprime les alinéas
qui je crois devrait vous conduire à
retirer cet amendement les alinéas que
vous supprimez dans l'article c'est une
avancée pour les contractuels de la
fonction publique puisque ce que nous
faisons avec ce projet de loi c'est de
faire en sorte que des agents
contractuels qui font parfois le même
métier que des agents qui sont en
catégorie active et qui de bénéficient
ni du C2P ni du bénéfice de la catégorie
active et bien puisse bénéficier après
cette réforme quand elle sera adoptée
du fait que leurs années de service
passaient en tant que contractuel soit
comptabilisé dans leur durée de service
c'est une avancée pour les agents de la
fonction publique et il s'avère je le
prends comme illustration justement de
l'intérêt du dialogue social que nous
avons eu que c'était une revendication
ancienne des organisations syndicales et
que nous avons donné suite à cette
revendication dans le cadre de la
préparation de ce projet de loi faire en
sorte que les années passées en tant
contractuel puissent être comptabilisés
dans la durée de service qui leur
permettra de partir un peu plus tôt
c'est cela que vous venez de supprimer
en revenant supprimer les alinés à 61 63
donc je recommande le retrait de cette
amendement
il est maintenu
oui écoutez on a vraiment du mal à
croire tout ce que vous nous racontez
depuis tout à l'heure on va vérifier on
regardera mais en tous les cas on ne
vous croit pas parce que on a compris
que de toute façon votre lettre motive
depuis des jours et des jours c'est fait
c'était de faire travailler les gens
plus longtemps or vous nous excusez vous
essayez depuis tout à l'heure quand
c'est pas Monique Lubin ou arrêt mon
ponce ou à moi-même de nous donner des
leçons écoutez on n'a pas de leçon à
recevoir de vous
la courtoisie étant une valeur
sénatoriale il faut être attentif madame
Lyman pour expliquer son vote
et déjà entendu plusieurs fois
l'argument de monsieur le ministre sur
la continuité des contractuels qui quand
ils deviendraient à Jean pourrait
bénéficier de leur année de
contractuelle et c'est vrai que c'est
plutôt une avancée mais mais
j'en reviens au nombre de contractuels
dans la fonction publique
parce que de la même manière que je
reprends mon raisonnement sur le fait
que la participation de l'État au
financement des retraites va être
stabilisée dont je vous rappelle qu'en
2070 ça fait presque plus de la moitié
du déficit public est lié au fait du
manque de recettes par l'État vous ne
m'avez pas répondu là-dessus
et la masse salariale maintenue c'est à
la fois le gel c'est à la fois on crée
pas des emplois mais c'est aussi en tout
cas pas des emplois stables de la
fonction publique et on va avoir la
multiplication des postes de
contractuels qui vont continuer à
déstabiliser une fonction publique
aurait besoin d'être valorisée je
rajoute à cela l'argument sur la CNRACL
vous a pas échappé que tout ce qui avait
on a eu le débat je ne veux pas être
longue sur ce point mais nous avons eu
le débat sur la CNRACL et qu'est-ce
qu'on a pu découvrir et mettre en
exergue c'est que en disons en serrant
le la gorge des collectivités locales
c'était la façon dont vous pouviez
réduire la masse salariale de la
fonction publique territoriale en
réduisant les services publics et la
boucle est bouclée alors une toute
petite avancer pour quelques
contractuels qui seront titularisés et
la masse la masse de contractualité qui
vont se poursuivre voir se développer
franchement le compte n'y est pas
c'est mon
merci monsieur le Président alors vous
dites souvent effectivement que la durée
de service active vous l'avez pas
modifié vous avez raison mais en deux
réformes en deux réformes on est passé
de durée de service actif 15 ans
de 15 ans à l'âge anticipé 55 ans c'est
à dire on pouvait partir à 15 ans
après 15 ans à 55 ans première réforme
17 ans à 57 ans votre réforme 17 ans à
59 ans donc effectivement vous dégradez
quand même la genticiper puisqu'il passe
de 57 à 59 vous ne dégradez pas la durée
de service active vous laissez à 17 ans
alors que la réforme précédente avait
dégradé les deux facteurs mais je
voudrais vous dire que ne pas dégrader
un indicateur c'est pas ce que j'appelle
moi un progrès social c'est comme la
décote vous la dégradez pas l'âge de la
décote c'est comme la validité
permanente que vous avez laissé au même
âge et vous croyez tellement qu'une non
dégradation est un progrès social que y
compris je l'ai déjà dit vous mettez la
validité permanente qui n'a pas qui a eu
son âge maintenu vous le mettez en
mesure
d'accompagnement en mesure sociale alors
j'ai le temps là maintenant de dire
voilà un syndicaliste qui avait signé un
accord très très dégradé c'est pour ça
et à qui je disais mais tu as signé
quand même quelque chose tout va mal il
m'a dit oui mais nous avons gagné par
rapport à ce que nous pouvions perdre
nous avons gagné par rapport à ce que
nous pouvions perdre c'est ce que ce que
vous nous dites souvent c'est à dire ce
que vous n'avez pas perdu c'est un
progrès social public
il est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin avec l'eau
345 votants 343 exprimés pour 93 contre
250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté ça n'a pas
si à l'examen de 5 amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune d'abord
l'amendement 248 de Monsieur Pacaud
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur messieurs les ministres
collègues cet amendement vise par
l'abrogation d'un article du code de
l'éducation à corriger une injustice à
rétablir l'équité entre les professeurs
des écoles et les enseignants du
secondaire quant à l'âge légal
d'ouverture de leurs droits à la
retraite concrètement depuis 91 1991 un
professeur des écoles ne peut prendre ne
peut pas prendre sa retraite en cours
d'année il doit aller jusqu'à la fin de
l'année scolaire ce qui n'est pas le cas
de son collègue du secondaire donc
concrètement vous avez deux personnes
qui sont nées le 5 septembre le
professeur des écoles il ira jusqu'au
début du mois de juillet suivant alors
que son collègue pourra rendre qui est
professeur en collège pourra ranger son
ordinateur ses cahiers ses crayons et
faire son pot de départ le 5 septembre
c'est une mesure d'équité qui est
attendue par tous les professeurs des
écoles et réclamé par les syndicats
1910 monsieur lévrier le présente
effectivement comme la très bien
défendue mon collègue Paco c'est un
souci d'égalité de traitement
essentiellement du second degré puisque
c'est un mandement visa supprimé la
disposition qui oblige les enseignants
du premier degré à poursuivre leur
activité jusqu'à la fin d'un année
scolaire lorsque ces derniers ont réuni
les conditions de départ en retraite
durant cette même année je n'oublie pas
mes 30 ans passer au service de
l'enseignement et je profite de cette
prise de parole pour saluer le travail
des enseignants leur dévouement leur
engagement au service des jeunes qui
sont et seront la France de demain c'est
avant demain qui fit à faciliter leur
départ en retraite va dans le sens d'une
meilleure prise en compte de leur
parcours et d'une plus grande équité
merci beaucoup
alors nous avions un amendement 2255 de
Madame sur le groupe qui était identique
qui a été retiré un amendement de 1954
rectifiés qui le présente Madame Monnier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre Michel collègue donc ça a déjà
été dit en fait on supprime l'article
921-4 du code éducation qui contraint
les enseignantes et enseignants du
premier degré à se maintenir en activité
jusqu'à la fin de l'année scolaire
lorsqu'ils ont atteint au cours de cette
même année les conditions de départ à la
retraite d'abord je me réjouis vraiment
que cette demande de suppression soit
portée par de nombreux collègues au sein
de cette hémicycle elle vise en effet à
corriger une inégalité qui n'a que trop
perturbé et qui si elle n'est pas
aujourd'hui remise en question conduira
de fait des personnels à se maintenir en
poste au-delà de 64 ans une double peine
alors qu'il est elles sont les plus
nombreux à partir avec une décote parmi
l'ensemble des personnels de l'éducation
nationale par moins de 34% non seulement
10% d'entre eux partent avec une des
côtes de moins de 5% ce départ avant
d'avoir atteint le taux plein et bien
sûr lié à l'impossibilité de partir en
cours de l'année scolaire mais il doit
aussi nous interroger plus largement sur
la nécessité d'améliorer les conditions
de travail de nos enseignantes et de nos
enseignants ainsi que l'aménagement de
leur fin de carrière j'invite d'ailleurs
le gouvernement à s'en saisir en lien
avec les partenaires sociaux
je suis perdu
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
effectivement les instituteurs on les
appelle maintenant les professeurs des
écoles sont je crois bien les seuls
actifs à pas pouvoir choisir leur date
précise de départ à la retraite en clair
il ne partent à la retraite qu'au terme
d'une année scolaire complexe
c'est-à-dire le 31 août bien sûr il est
essentiel de d'assurer la stabilité le
suivi annuel du corps enseignant près
des élèves mais un changement
d'enseignant s'il est bien anticipé ça
ne sera pas source d'instabilité
d'autant que l'État ont changé et
l'époque de l'instituteur seul dans une
classe unique n'est plus le modèle
dominant loin de là les conditions
d'aujourd'hui dans la grande majorité
des écoles primaires le permet de sans
difficulté imaginons un professeur des
écoles on l'appellera à aller au hasard
Jean-Pierre liégeois avec sa date
anniversaire au 15 septembre pour un
départ à 64 ans il devra compter un an
de plus pour assurer un service
qui ont servi jusqu'à la fin de l'année
scolaire donc un départ en réalité à 65
ans aujourd'hui donc du fait de cette
règle du 31 août ce sont quand même ça a
des conséquences très pratiques et
difficiles parce que c'est son 34 % des
personnels du premier degré qui partent
avec une décote et ce nombre est
nettement plus important que leurs
collègues du second degré c'est le signe
de quoi c'est le signe que beaucoup de
professeurs des écoles du fait de
l'impossibilité de partir à la retraite
en cours d'année scolaire sont en
quelque sorte acculés à partir plus tôt
à la retraite pour ne pas faire l'année
de trop pour leur santé et pour éviter
trop de pénibilité au travail c'est dur
en fin de carrière donc il s'agit je
crois de lever cette contrainte UNIQUE
et anachronique alors
madame
de dire
l'école sur le
fait les professeurs des écoles sont les
seuls qui ne peuvent pas partir à le
jour où ils ont choisi en retraites et
qu'ils doivent faire une année complète
jusqu'au 31 août
ça les injustices et les inégalités avec
leurs collègues du second degré ont été
pointés il faut savoir que les
professeurs d'écoles partent en moyenne
deux ans avant ceux du second degré pour
les raisons qui ont été expliquées c'est
que c'est un métier lui aussi
usant et que les enseignants ne veulent
pas faire l'année de trop qui peut
parfois les conduire à des catastrophes
et donc en gros ils partent pour les
hommes un peu plus de 61 ans pour les
femmes un tout petit peu plus de 60 ans
c'est des parts se font ça a été
expliqué avec des décote un tiers un
tiers des profs d'école partent avec des
décotes et je crois que nous vivons à un
moment de manque d'attractivité une
crise de recrutement des enseignants et
qu'effectivement corriger cette
inégalité serait de nature à renforcer
l'attractivité de ce métier merci David
la commission sur monsieur le rapporteur
ces amendements
identiques puis un amendement un peu
différent qu'on a brûlée
favorable
cette alignement sur l'ensemble des
professeurs des enseignants simplement
j'ai une question à poser
messieurs les ministres qu'en pensent
monsieur le ministre de l'Éducation
quand on remplacement quand un
enseignant ça va s'en va au milieu d'une
année scolaire est-ce que vous avez des
propositions nous formuler merci
monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le Président
vous doutez bien que c'est évidemment
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Papé Ndiaye que cette mesure a
été discutée et je peux vous confirmer
que le gouvernement sera favorable à
adopter cette amendement et c'est le
souhait du ministre de l'éducation
nationale mais vous posez la bonne
question qui est celle au fond de
l'organisation des établissements
scolaires c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous menons d'ores et déjà un travail
avec le secrétaire général du ministère
avec la direction des ressources
humaines du ministère pour rendre cette
mesure effectivement et pour laisser la
liberté je le dis aussi au professeur
pour pouvoir continuer jusque à la fin
de l'année scolaire et leur laisser
évidemment le libre choix et je pense
que d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
professeurs du primaire feront le choix
de continuer à travailler et d'être
devant leur classe jusqu'à la fin de
l'année mais c'est dans cet état
d'esprit là que nous devons rendre cette
mesure qui est une belle avancée qui
vient mettre
fin à une injustice effective pour
l'ensemble des professeurs je crois que
cette mesure est attendue et donc je
vous invite à l'adopter merci
je vais consulter par avant attendez
monsieur salmon demander à expliquer son
vote et Madame Monnier
merci monsieur le Président
regardons un petit peu en arrière
les professeurs des écoles dont on parle
aujourd'hui était avant des instituteurs
ils étaient en service actif il partait
et c'est pas si vieux que ça il partait
à 55 ans
ensuite on est passé à 57 ans
aujourd'hui les professeurs des écoles
72 ans alors là c'est vrai qu'on est un
peu grand prince on se dit aujourd'hui
et bah oui on va les laisser partir et
bien en cours d'année mais ça rejoint un
peu ce que disait ma collègue Raymond de
Poncet c'est-à-dire que en fin de compte
on perd on perd et en fin de compte on
fait mine que et bien ce sont des
avancées des avancées sociales non on a
une dégradation qui est terrible on le
voit au niveau des enseignants du
primaire qui sont dans un mal-être je
vais dire pratiquement absolu avec des
conditions de travail qui se dégradent
avec des arrêts qui sont de plus en plus
fréquents et des moyens de remplacement
qui sont pas toujours à la hauteur avec
effectivement des classes qui sont
si ce n'est surchargé du moins fort
rempli avec de nombreux enfants avec des
troubles du comportement effectivement
on a une usure une usure terrible de ces
enseignants qui sont eux aussi en
première ligne et que l'on oublie bien
souvent alors je pense que il faut voter
bien entendu cette amendement mais
quelque part on est dans un pays parce
que on n'a pas pris en compte toutes ces
difficultés qui s'accumulent aujourd'hui
merci
monsieur le Président je complèterai les
propos de mon collègue par aussi le
salaire des enseignants qui est bien
moins attractif et qui s'est
terriblement dégradé pendant ces années
et je voudrais aussi revenir un petit
peu sur les autres paramètres vecteurs
de stress pour ces personnels qui
manquent parfois aussi de soutien de la
part de la direction de leur hiérarchie
une réalité qui incarne bien le chiffre
terrible de la dernière enquête au CDE
seul 4% des professeurs des écoles
considèrent que leur métier est valorisé
et revenir aussi sur le remplacement
c'est vrai qu'il va falloir les
remplacer mais quand même un départ à la
retraite ça s'anticipe c'est une date
qui est prévue donc je vois pas pourquoi
ce serait une difficulté pour organiser
la remplacement alors maintenant je
consulte ceux qui sont favorables à
l'adoption de cette amendement qui a
reçu un avis fera du Gouvernement et la
commission a été éclairée une manifeste
enlevant la main
avis contraire attention il était adopté
et il faut tomber le dernier
voilà quatre amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement
3627 madame ponce merci Monsieur
président
à garder ce grand enthousiasme unanime
on a beaucoup parlé de l'impact de cet
article 7 sur des métiers je voudrais
quand même avant qu'il ne soit minuit
vous parlez de l'impact sur les femmes
cette réforme nous le disons est une
réforme anti-féministe selon le rapport
d'information fait au nom de la
délégation au droit des femmes du Sénat
d'attente de 2013 toutes les réformes
sur les retraites ont pénalisé les
femmes et celles-ci ne fait pas
exception alors un facteur indéfacteurs
alors qu'aujourd'hui les femmes
travaillent en moyenne 7 mois de plus
que les hommes avec cette réforme elles
vont en moyenne devoir travailler 9 mois
de plus alors que c'est 5 pour les
hommes cela dépend des générations vous
me direz mais c'est toujours toujours
dans ce sens plus ou moins mais toujours
au détriment des femmes pas un exemple
pour la génération 80 l'impact pour les
femmes sera de 8 mois d'allongement pour
les hommes ça sera de 4 mois je vous
invite un calcul mathématique c'est deux
fois plus et je vais vous donner un
autre calcul de cette de cet effet
de l'allongement si on exclut les 67 ans
ou les femmes je vous le rappelle
partent deux fois plus puisqu'elle elles
attendent de le taux plein si on exclut
donc les 67 ans essayez on exclut aussi
ceux qui ne sont pas touchés
l'invalidité j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure si on excuse ces deux catégories
les femmes vont devoir travailler 14
mois de plus et 11 mois pour les hommes
donc c'est un des facteurs mais c'est
pas le seul nous en reparlerons lors du
minimum contributif c'est un des
facteurs qui fait que les économistes le
disent 60% de la réforme 60% des
économies vont peser sur les femmes si
ça c'est pas une réforme anti-féministe
je vous demande ce que c'est alors vous
avez un amendement suivant madame pour
simonge 3597
monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le Président c'est moi
qui vais profiter de cette amendement
puisque comme vous l'avez constaté
toutes et tous de nombreux sous
amendements qui étaient précédemment des
amendements ont été déclarés
irrecevables je profite donc de cette
occasion pour reprendre on va dire la
main sur un certain nombre de métiers
dont la pénibilité
est tout à fait présente les auxiliaires
de puériculture et les ambulanciers deux
métiers passionnants mais aussi
physiquement et psychologiquement
usant
porté d'enfants tâche répétitives pour
les auxiliaires de vie en puériculture
des conditions dégradées
occupées à 97% par des femmes avec des
postures pénibles qui finissent par user
les corps
pour les ambulanciers des horaires
décalés des conditions dégradées qui
font qu'il manque aujourd'hui 15000
ambulanciers du fait d'une grande vague
de démission
ce sont des professionnels fatigués
devenus parfois inapte qui parfois
jettent l'éponge alors que ces métiers
sont cruciaux c'est des métiers ce sont
des métiers vitaux pour notre société
pour toutes ces raisons on l'allongement
de la durée des cotisations et
incompatible avec les contraintes de ces
métiers alors je sais que parler de
métiers par les gens
énervent parfois quelques personnes dans
des rangs à droite ici et que certains
préfèrent parler de chiffres et de
statistiques et ne pas voir que derrière
se trouvent des femmes et des hommes en
chair et en os
ces chiffres vont faire payer très cher
ces deux années supplémentaires
alors
monsieur le elec
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
les travailleurs du monde agricole qui
représentent dans notre pays un million
300000 personnes quasiment ont un sort
plus précaires que le reste des Français
pendant la retraite bien entendu il ne
vous aura pas échappé il ne m'a pas
échappé ici l'avancée importante qu'on
constitue les lois Chassaignes
chassaient mieux de même que il ne m'a
pas échappé non plus le vote particulier
que nous avons commis ici il y a
quelques semaines sur les 25 meilleures
annuités mais il reste aujourd'hui que
la situation des travailleurs de la
terre est très compliqué alors qu'il
travaille plus que beaucoup d'autres
catégories il passe au moins 54 heures
par semaine au travail et ne prennent
quasiment jamais de congé
or au moment de prendre sa retraite les
assurés du régime agricole continuent à
manquer continuent à survivre continuer
à manquer de ressources c'est aussi ce
que nous disent les jeunes qui observent
ces métiers avec beaucoup de prudence
pour ne pas dire beaucoup de
circonspection
or ce sont des centaines de milliers de
jeunes dont nous avons besoin pour
assurer la relève dans le monde agricole
d'ailleurs la question de la
transmission est en soi un véritable
sujet de portée nationale il nous
apparaît donc évident qu'il faudrait
améliorer substantiellement les
conditions de vie des agriculteurs
augmenter leur pension et donner donc
plus d'attractivité au métier c'est
l'inverse que nous faisons et ce n'est
pas une bonne chose du point de vue de
notre souveraineté agricole et
alimentaire merci de votre attention
et
vous voulez bien préparer vos
amendements puisque
pardonnez-moi
monsieur l'abbé oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur collègue je vais vous
parler de par cet amendement des liens
entre la vie politique locale et les
retraites
parmi les conséquences délétères de la
réforme nous pouvons compter l'impact
sur la vie politique locale en effet
lors des dernières élections municipales
l'âge moyen des nouveaux maires était de
58,9 années l'Association des maires de
France note que les mers sont de plus en
plus âgées en 2020
55,3% des mers avec plus de 60 ans après
le dernier scrutin local évidemment
cette cette réforme ne va pas arranger
les choses de la même manière la
moindreissement du tissu associatif est
à craindre selon une étude de la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse datant
de 2013 un dirigeant d'associations sur
deux est un retraité le passage à la
retraite favorise la vie associative
puisque chez les 55 à 65 ans le taux de
participation des retraités est
supérieur à celui des non-rétés
et 38% des retraités tous âges confondus
sont adhérents à au moins une
association selon une étude encore entre
2010 et 2019 pour conclure le taux
d'aménagement
d'engagement à diminuer chez les plus
âgés parmi les
causes les plus probables d'une baisse
de l'engagement de l'augmentation de
l'âge du départ à la retraite je vous
remercie alors l'avis de la commission
oui là encore mais chaque collègue sont
des amendements de suppression d'alinéa
et dans lequel la présentation
n'est pas d'une grande évidence merci au
niveau du groupe
pour l'amendement numéro
3580 n'en parlons pour l'amendement
présenté au nom de Madame assassy pour
notre collègue effectivement
sa présentation correspond tout à fait à
l'objet de l'amendement par contre
madame poncer Monge vous nous avez
présenté un discours forte intéressant
bien entendu comme d'habitude mais qui
est plus une parole prise pour nous
souligner la position que vous défendez
mais qui n'a rien à voir avec
l'amendement vous proposez de supprimer
des et des alinés à vous nous parlez
dans l'objet d'une meilleure répartition
des richesses c'est intéressant des
milliers des milliardaires français et
puis également du rétablissement de la
retraite à 60 ans c'est quand même
extraordinaire on voit bien les
difficultés de l'équilibre d'un système
par répartition et vous restez encore
ancré dans ce type de proposition
c'est pas c'est pas sincère quand même
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens on sait
très bien que ça peut plus se passer
comme ça c'est la raison pour laquelle
soyons attentifs on sent bien que la
renéo a tourné c'est toujours le même
discours et véritablement ce type
d'amendement pourrait être interprété
par certains comme de l'obstruction donc
soyez attentif à vos exposés de motifs
merci Monsieur le Ministre du socle
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement l'amendement 43004 a été
présenté en évoquant la situation des
retraités de l'agriculture et c'est
l'objet de l'amendement ça me permet de
souligner que dans le cadre du projet de
loi nous allons faire en sorte que la
fameuse garantie Chassaigne soit
accordée aux agriculteurs qui ont
interrompu leur carrière avant son terme
du fait d'une incapacité ou d'une
invalidité puisque aujourd'hui pour
bénéficier de la garantie Chassaigne il
faut avoir une carrière complète mais
une carrière complète et intégralement
complète nous proposons d'élargir la
définition de la carrière complète pour
les agriculteurs exploitants à ceux qui
ont dû quitter cette activité avant leur
terme pour un problème de santé cela va
permettre à 45 000 retraités des
exploitants agricoles retraités de
bénéficier d'une revalorisation autant
de 80 euros par mois en moyenne je pense
que c'est une bonne chose parce que ça
permet de boucher un trou dans la
raquette des deux PPL pour les trois
autres présentations de Madame penser
mon je me suis Ferny je crois et
Monsieur l'abbé vous nous avez parlé de
la situation des femmes et c'est un
sujet évidemment majeur vous nous avez
parlé de la situation des élus locaux or
les amendements vous avez présenté
supprime des alinéas qui concernent pour
les deux premiers les retraités de
l'agriculture et pour le dernier la
retraite des demandeurs d'emploi il y a
un grand écart entre ce dont vous avez
parlé et ce que vous proposez par les
amendements et par ailleurs dans ces
amendements s'ils étaient adoptés il y
aurait qu'un seul résultat de justement
fragiliser le régime de retraite des
exploitants agricoles et des demandeurs
d'emploi donc la vie est évidemment
défavorable
alors je vais consulter
oui merci monsieur le Président j'étais
un peu surpris par ce que vient de dire
monsieur le ministre enfin c'est pas la
première fois qu'on est un peu surpris
je crois que Joël Labbé a insisté sur un
point extrêmement important et il y a
dans les conseils municipaux des
communes rurales beaucoup justement de
regretter de retraités du monde agricole
cette retraite fait alors que la
décennie donna soixantaine c'est
vraiment la décennie de l'investissement
dans la vie associative et dans la vie
municipale nous savons que notre système
démocratique il fonctionne sur
l'investissement de ces jeunes retraités
dans les conseils municipaux nous savons
tous qu'on a eu du mal y compris dans
des communes moyennes avoir plus d'une
liste sur des élections y compris des
communes à 10 15000 habitants ça c'est
notre réalité si vous partez à la
retraite après 64 ans à partir 63 ans
vous vous projetez six ans après vous
projetez dans la décennie d'après et
vous à vous investir dans la vie
municipale et vous vous investissez
moins longtemps dans la vie associative
monsieur le ministre votre réforme avec
une logique comptable et Monsieur Savary
vient d'avoir une logique comptable qui
en plus passe pour silence le
déséquilibre entre les revenus du
capital et les revenus du travail tels
qu'ils ont évolué depuis 30 ans mais
passons sur ce point votre réforme
monsieur le ministre on ne compte pas
l'ensemble des coûts pour la société
française est en train d'appauvrir la
société française elle est en train de
fragiliser la société française et ne
pas entendre l'ensemble des coûts
induits par cette réforme va être
absolument catastrophique dans les
prochaines années y compris pour notre
vie démocratique locale
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi je fais une explication les
bottes sur les amendements présentés par
notre collègue Raymond poncemonge et
elle a raison puisqu'on est le 8 mars
donc il s'agit pas de faire ici le
concours de la plus ou du plus pénalisé
par cette réforme mais dire que cette
réforme ne corrige en rien les
inégalités salariales et les inégalités
de pension est une réalité et ça va
dégrader encore la situation des femmes
les chiffres sont clairs parmi les
retraités nés en 1950 un tiers n'était
ni en emploi ni au chômage l'année
précédant la retraite c'est 37% des
femmes pour 28% des hommes et entre 55
et 65 ans chers collègues on se retrouve
souvent dans des situations
particulières qui fait que des parents
âgés dépendants nécessite de prendre du
temps sur des carrières et il se trouve
aussi qu'entre 55 et 65 ans des enfants
âgés avec des petits enfants demandent
aussi du temps au grand-parents pour
prendre pour répondre à l'absence
parfois de pénurie d'accueil de la
petite enfance donc oui je voterais les
amendements présentés par Madame
poncemonge bien je consulte ceux qui ont
reçu à double avis défavorable pour le
3627 ceux qui sont pour le manifestants
devant la main
la vie contraire
je suis saisi demande de scrutin public
pour deux amendements identiques
3597 et le
4304 c'est le groupe communiste qui nous
les demandes je vais
consulter le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
avec l'eau
345 votants 342 exprimés 93 pour 249
contre le Sénat n'a pas adopté nous
passons au vote sur le
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
manifeste on le voit la main
avis contraire il n'est pas adopté
nous allons examiner deux amendements
identiques ensuite
madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors moi
j'aimerais intervenir pour oui pour dire
à Monsieur les ministres que tout comme
le directeur de la CNAV je ne crois pas
le groupe écologiste ne croit pas à
l'effet horizon
car les études se multiplient et sont
unanimes la réforme de 2010 a été
délétère pour l'emploi des seniors selon
l'Insee le report de l'âge 62 ans s'est
traduit par une hausse du taux d'emploi
à 60 ans de 14 points certes et je le
redis c'est beaucoup aussi les faits de
la noria générationnelle mais bon bref
mettons 14 points grâce à cette réforme
mais du taux de chômage souvent de
longue durée de 13 points et de 7 points
pour la validité
qui a sorti une étude il y a quelque
chose quelques jours qui montre qu'elle
a provoqué une hausse des allocataires
de l'assurance chômage de 100 000
personnes le pic des ruptures de contrat
à 59 ans et net dans cette étude et
n'est pas personne selon une étude de
l'Apec
81% des 112000 cadres de plus de 55 ans
qui sont aujourd'hui au chômage ont été
licenciés et ce n'est monsieur le
rapporteur ni un CDI senior
donc on peut douter que la seule
exonération des cotisations familles va
les faire réembaucher ni un index
Seigneur Seigneur Seigneur pardon qui
changeront cette donne actuellement 1,4
millions de seniors ne sont ni en emploi
ni en retraite les études l'ont montré
le report de l'âge à 64 ans c'est 150000
personnes de plus par an au RSA enfin
dans les minimaires sociaux ou au
chômage les 865 000 chômeurs seniors
longue durée vont partir de cette
réforme par le déplacement de leur sas
de précarité le déplacement je dis bien
de deux ans de plus et pas l'annulation
par l'effet d'horizon auquel vous croyez
ensuite un amendement 435 qui qui le
présente Madame linman
oui nous avons évoqué tout à l'heure le
cas des instituteurs enfin des
professeurs des écoles qui pouvaient
qui ne pouvait pas partir avant la fin
de l'année scolaire qu'ils avaient
engagé ils ne sont pas les seuls
concernés par ce mécanisme c'est vrai
des contractuels de l'éducation les
maîtres contractuelle c'est vrai des
personnels d'inspection et donc je crois
que cet amendement élargi le champ des
personnels de l'Éducation nationale qui
peuvent être concernés de la même
manière à minimale et mettre contractuel
ça paraît aussi une évidence
merci alors l'avis de la commission sur
ces deux amendements identiques sur
lequel je suis Céline une demande de
scrutin public
merci avis défavorable défavorables
de ma vie que le rapporteur mais ma vie
je vais soumettre scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert
345 votants 342 exprimés 93 pour 249
comptes cela n'a pas adopté un
amendement 439 monsieur gay
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres Richard collègues votre projet
de loi en temps par la modification de
l'article
l556-7 du code des pensions civiles et
militaires autoriser les fonctionnaires
dont la limite d'Agen est inférieure à
67 ans non plus à un maintien en
activité jusqu'à la tente d'un taux
plein mais un prolongation d'activité
ces deux dispositifs ne relèvent pas de
la même logique le maintien en fonction
est en effet pour les catégories dont la
limite d'âge et inférieur à 67 ans le
dernier recours après épuisement des
autres voies permettant d'arriver à un
taux maximum de cotisations et surtout
destiné à pallier une situation
exceptionnelle destinée en général à
régulariser un dépassement irrégulier la
limite d'âge agent détaché oubliés ou
fin d'année d'enseignements ce maintien
d'ailleurs à corps des temporairement et
sous réserve de l'intérêt de service ce
caractère singulier du maintien en
activité surtout pour les catégories non
syndr
mettre en parallèle avait le
vieillissement des effectifs signalé
dans le jeûne budgétaire du projet de
loi des finances pour 2022 plus d'un
agent sur trois dans la fonction
publique d'État à plus de 50 ans près de
1 sur 2 en fonction publique
territoriale et il est et il et elle
sont un sur trois dans la fonction
publique hospitalière pourtant en grande
partie plaçant catégorie active en effet
le jaune note que le nombre de
fonctionnaires âgés de 60 ans continue
sa progression plus prononcée en 2019
plus 5,2 qui avait déjà été entamé en
2008 2018 la hausse devrait s'accentuer
les prochaines années par effet
démographique monsieur le ministre
doit-on comprendre que vous souhaitez
normaliser une situation qui devrait
demeurer exceptionnelle mais que vous
allez contraindre à l'habitude et
doit-on comprendre que vous remplacez
une mesure d'exception par une
incitation au travail augmenter de
quelle année je vous remercie
alors la vie de la commission sur le
rapporteur défavorable monsieur le
Président
bien je vais consulter ceux qui sont
favorables à l'adoption qui vient de
présenter de l'amendement présenter
monsieur gay le manifestant devant la
main avis contraire
pas adopté et nous allons examiner
quatre amendements
identiques
de 84 rectifiés bis madame la Présidente
Nathalie Delattre merci monsieur le
Président c'est amenant un peu technique
propose en premier lieu d'intrigue au
code général de la Fonction publique la
limite d'âge au sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels en cohérence avec la
codification des limites d'âge
applicable au fonctionnaires des
catégories actives il est ainsi proposé
de décaler l'âge à partir duquel le
congé pour raison opérationnelle peut
être pris sur la base de l'âge de départ
anticipé afin de respecter la durée
maximale de 5 années de ce congé enfin
en second lieu en cohérence avec
l'extension du bénéfice de l'âge de
départ anticipé lorsque le fonctionnaire
n'est plus en catégorie active et avec
les mesures prévues pour les autres
corps et cadres d'emploi cet amendement
propose d'étendre le principe de
portabilité à la bonification de service
aux sapeurs-pompiers professionnels je
vous remercie
merci
l'amendement suivant et un amendement
que présente
monsieur venonville oui monsieur le
Président il a été défendu par la
présidente de Lattre c'est un amendement
identique merci il est défendu
l'amendement
4400 rectifié monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues il y a des métiers
idéalisés dans l'imaginaire collectif
notamment celui des pompiers puisqu'ils
sont vus à juste titre comme des héros
prêts à courir tous les dangers pour
sauver nos proches un voisin ou
nous-mêmes malgré le rêve que représente
cette profession notamment chez les plus
jeunes personnes nées dupes sur la
difficulté de ce métier à la fois
physique et psychologique les situations
sont variées mais souvent difficiles
parce qu'elle touche à l'intime et dans
des conditions souvent dramatiques il
s'agit là d'un critère qui serait déjà
suffisant pour considérer les
sapeurs-pompiers comme appartenant à
cette catégorie dite active
nous nous invitons donc à voter cet
amendement mais au-delà de cette
pénibilité il y a une autre réalité
celle des besoins et des moyens humains
plus vous dégradez les conditions de
travail et de carrière des pompiers
moins vous parviendrez à recruter et
plus vous mettrez en danger l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens et concitoyens après
les déserts médicaux vivre en nous
bientôt dans des airs complets
d'assistance souhaitez-vous que les
pompiers soient aussi âgés que les
personnes qui viennent régulièrement
relever après une chute n'ajoutons pas
de la souffrance à l'injustice merci
merci alors la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur sur ces
amendements identiques disposition tout
à fait indispensable à vie favorable
avis favorable
oui également à vivre favorable ce sont
des dispositions qui vont dans le sens
voulu par les syndicats notamment qui
représentent pardon monsieur le
Président puis je ne pourrai pas je
mange je m'en voudrais moi-même
ce Président Madame
Nathalie Delattre ayant le même
amendement que le mien l'a très bien
défendu donc voilà il est donc à la fois
défendu et soutenu monsieur le ministre
vous pouvez répondre à Madame chinager
exactement avec un avis favorable du
Gouvernement également du ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin nous avons
reçu les organisations syndicales des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires et
professionnels il y a quelques jours
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur ce sont
des dispositions qui vont dans le bon
sens et donc l'amendement porté est
évidemment soutenu
je rappelle que je suis saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public sur ces quatre
amendements monsieur le Président kaner
pour expliquer son vote oui au non mon
groupe monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres nous soutiendrons ses
amendements nous sommes quelques-uns
entre guillemets sénateurs spécialistes
entre guillemets des sapeurs-pompiers
professions que nous défendons sur tous
les bancs de cette émission
notamment je pense à ce rapport que nous
avons commis sur la protection physique
des sapeurs-pompiers au regard notamment
des agressions qui subissent très
régulièrement et pas uniquement dans les
quartiers prioritaires de de la ville
donc ces amendements vont dans le bon
sens c'est une exception à la règle que
vous voulez imposer à l'ensemble des
Français mais c'est une bonne exception
qui fera l'objet d'un soutien favorable
de notre part
bien le scrutin est ouvert
les pompiers font l'unanimité 345 voient
pour 0 voix contre voilà
laissez là donc adopter un amendement
qui le présente Madame
pour ces Monges
alors ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure et
on tient le dire et à le redire depuis
30 ans le travail s'est intensifié pour
toutes les catégories et y compris les
cadres par exemple on va prendre les
cartes parce que c'est là on y pense pas
forcément 2% des cas des exposés à au
moins trois contraintes physiques en
1984 je parle bien de contraintes
physiques pas des contraintes
temporelles ou sur le sur le rythme de
travail ils sont ils sont passés de 2 à
26% selon l'adresse même pour eux le
travail est plus intense et plus pénible
et pour les ouvriers bien entendu c'est
pire le nombre d'ouvriers déclarant
subir au moins trois contraintes de
rythme alors qu'ils sont plutôt des
contraintes de cadre était de 8% 8 7 en
84 ils sont aujourd'hui de
53,4%. soit 1 sur 2 ouvriers qui a des
contraintes de rythme par ailleurs 64%
sont exposés des agents chimiques
dangereux 62% vibrations mécaniques vous
reconnaissez j'espère monsieur le
ministre les pénibilités que vous avez
exclues du CDP face à cela le
gouvernement réagit lors du précédent
quinquennat effectivement pour retirer
ces critères de pénibilité jusqu'à vider
le C2P de son contenu comme le signalait
la Cour des comptes
donc c'est cet impact là sur lequel nous
voulons alerter nous pouvons pas voter
une réforme des retraites qui ne parle
pas du problème central celui du travail
et celui des conditions de travail nous
ne pouvons pas voter un texte qui ne
tient pas compte de l'accroissement de
la vulnérabilité des seniors donc qu'ils
vont devoir faire deux ans de plus face
au travail alors même que la réforme de
2010 je le rappelle a fortement augmenté
les arrêts maladie de longue durée des
employés seniors et selon l'adresse le
surcoût est estimé après après d'un
milliard pour un nouveau report à 64 ans
est-ce que c'est surcoût sont estimés
c'est les effets direct induits
indirects dont parlait tout à l'heure
mon collègue est-ce que le projet de loi
contient des dispositions à la hauteur
pour protéger les seniors au travail
merci
alors la vie de la commission Monsieur
Madame la rapporteur général
110 chers collègues et bien vous soyez
sur l'objet présenté tout de suite
puisque en fait c'est Linéa pourrait
supprimer des dispositions maintenant à
68 ans la limite d'âge applicable au
vice-président du Conseil d'État alors
voilà le dossier du Conseil des tactives
qui revient en réalité je pense que vous
n'avez pas choisi le bon alinéa c'est un
avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie mais ma vie je vais
consulter ceux qui sont favorables
manifestants devant la main
avis contraire
n'est pas adopté alors deux amendements
qui vont faire ils sont identiques
l'objet d'une discussion commune
monsieur ferrique
c'est Monsieur Gontard je suis désolé
merci monsieur le Président donc
effectivement il s'agit d'un moment de
suppression de la Linéa 121 à 123
c'est vrai que au-delà justement de la
suppression de cet anniversaire parce
que j'ai bien entendu madame la
rapporteur est-ce qu'elle a pu dire mais
je trouve que
sur l'ensemble de ces amendements ce qui
est ce qui est particulièrement
intéressant et la discussion qu'on peut
avoir ce soir même si vrai qu'il y a un
petit peu de un petit peu de brouhaha
pourtant je trouve que ça met bien en
valeur toutes les problématiques de
cette réforme votre choix de passer de
62 à 64 ans de manière uniforme ben on
voit bien que quand on liste l'ensemble
des métiers l'ensemble des professions
ben on voit bien qu'il y a des
particularités qu'on est obligé de de
faire de trouver des aménagements en
fonction en fonction des métiers on a pu
d'ailleurs enrichir ce texte au cours de
la soirée puisque des amendements ont
été votés et des amendements de très
partagés d'ailleurs que ça soit pour les
pompiers que ça soit pour les égoutiers
tout à l'heure et on a eu un débat
important sur les sportifs sur les
instituteurs et je pense que c'est
important à travers l'ensemble de ces
amendements à travers l'ensemble de ces
alinéas de montrer que bah oui voilà
toute la problématique de cette de cette
réforme de vouloir passer comme ça
donner deux ans de plus à chacun et
quand on regarde on voit bien que ça ne
fonctionne pas que ça ne marche pas
parce que on doit prendre en compte
cette pénibilité on doit prendre en
compte les différentes les différentes
spécificités et donc c'est tout le sujet
de ces différents amendements et
monsieur le ministre je voulais quand
même vous remercier parce que c'est vrai
que voilà vous êtes un peu plus
silencieux mais vous êtes assez
intervenu et avec des arguments et qu'au
cours de cette soirée et de l'ensemble
de ces de ces différents amendements on
a pu échanger et on a pu mener je trouve
un débat plutôt intéressant merci alors
madame Cohen présente le monde 4315
moi j'aimerais m'arrêter un peu sur la
profession des ingénieurs de contrôle de
la navigation aérienne plus connue
effectivement sous le nom de contrôleur
aérien le trafic aérien s'il n'était pas
là tournerait à la catastrophe ils sont
près de 4000 en France à guider nuit et
jour il y a 1,7 millions de volts par an
et à faire décoller atterrir les avions
en toute sécurité du haut de sa tour de
contrôle aiguilleur du ciel est
contraint de fixer plusieurs écrans et
tablettes 8 à 12 heures d'affilée ce
travail s'opère sous une forte astreinte
cognitive générée par la nécessité d'une
synchronisation temporelle et spatiale
avec le second écuyère aiguilleur et le
centre météo et naturellement le pilote
j'y suis particulièrement sensible ainsi
d'ailleurs que mon collègue Pascal ça
vole d'Élie puisque dans le Val-de-Marne
il y a l'aéroport d'Orly trop souvent la
fatigue due aux horaires alternés à la
surcharge de travail
donc ces professionnels à des burn out
un article du Parisien datant du 18
janvier dernier nous apprend que le
ministère des Transports s'est engagé à
ne pas toucher à l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite des contrôleurs du ciel qui
est aujourd'hui de 59 ans pour autant
l'accélération du passage à 43 annuités
pour bénéficier du taux plein mais en
exergue la nécessité de déplafonner la
bonification du cinquième du temps de
service pour ces ingénieurs de contrôle
de la navigation aérienne étant donné
que le bénéfice du complément individuel
temporaire n'est qu'un patch temporaire
basé sur des estimations et n'est jamais
revalorisée dans un contexte où la
question du pouvoir d'achat est brûlante
et qu'il reste encore beaucoup de manque
dans les pensions de retraite de ces
ingénieurs il nous semblait nécessaire
par le biais de cet amendement de repli
dans faire état et d'exprimer donc notre
soutien à la mobilisation de certains
syndicats de ce secteur contre cette
réforme des retraites et d'attirer votre
attention sur cette profession
spécifique
merci alors la vie de la commission
madame le rapporteur général oui de la
commission est toujours défavorable
parce qu'en fait on supprimant ces
années ces alinéas là et bien vous êtes
contraire à sans doute l'objectif que
vous voulez atteindre en fait puisque ce
sont des dispositions qui prévoit
l'ouverture du bénéfice de la
bonification du 5e du temps de service à
accompli aux anciens ingénieurs du
contrôle de la navigation aérienne et
donc en réalité c'était pas c'était pas
là qu'il fallait en tout cas agir pour
aller vers ce que vous souhaitiez pour
ces ingénieurs et la revalorisation de
leur émoluments si on peut dire donc
c'est un avis défavorable la vie du
gouvernement oui mais ma vie monsieur le
Président est pour aller dans le sens et
remercier le sénateur comptable de ses
propos effectivement encore une fois
nous portons une réforme d'effort et non
pas cette mesure qui est évidente mais
je veux faire valoir qu'il y a beaucoup
d'avancées et en l'occurrence la
portabilité des modifications c'est une
avance réelle et aujourd'hui vous avez
un système où quand vous êtes ingénieur
de contrôle de la navigation aérienne si
vous ne terminez pas votre carrière en
tant qu'ingénieur de la contrôle de la
délégation aérienne et bien vous ne
bénéficiez pas justement des
bonifications que vous avez acquises au
long de votre carrière et donc c'est à
ça que nous venons mettre fin et par
votre amendement vous viendrez supprimer
cette portabilité nouvelle que nous
apportons et donc nous invitons
effectivement à le retirer
merci alors je vais je suis saisi une
demande de scrutin public sur ces
amendements
le scrutin est ouvert
mais j'ai pas vu
le scrutin avec l'eau
votant 345 exprimé 343 pour 92 contre
le Sénat n'a pas adopté je vais aborder
deux amendements qui font l'objet du
discussion commune d'un amendement qui
porte le numéro 3608 qui le présente
Madame Monsieur dessus madame pensé
Monge
merci monsieur le Président alors nous
nous sommes en train d'achever l'article
7 et c'est vrai que nous essayons de
parler quand même de tous les impacts de
l'article 7 afin d'éclairer le vote
quand même au coeur des discussions
devrait figurer la conséquence devrait
figurer la conséquence des inégalités de
santé au travail et donc la conséquence
de l'allongement de la durée du travail
contenu des inégalités de santé au
travail selon laquelle elle l'enquête
giscope 93 9 patients sur 10 atteints de
concerts ont été exposés à au moins un
cancérogène au cours de sa vie
professionnelle selon le chercheur
Philippe davéziers la grande majorité
des maladies professionnelles reconnues
ne relèvent en effet que de deux
chapitres de pathologies
professionnelles les maladies dues à
l'amiante on le sait avec quel retard et
les pathologies de l'appareil locomothée
le commoteur et on le sait puisqu'ils ne
sont pas aussi dans l'essai de paix de
ne pas ils donnent pas possibilité de
partir en départ anticipé
les données scientifiques disponibles
permettent d'estimer que 8,5% des
cancers sont d'origine professionnelle
cela représente une fourchette entre
14000 et 30 000 nouveaux cancers
professionnels chaque année or le nombre
total de cancers professionnels reconnus
annuellement est inférieur à 3000
fourchettes 14000 à 30000 et reconnu
3000 ce déficit de reconnaissance des
cancers professionnels cette moindre
reprise en compte notamment de
l'exposition aux agents chimiques
dangereux et aux poussières sont les
principaux responsables des épidémies de
cancer due au travail et sont et alors
que cette exposition les travailleurs
ils sont inégalement exposés ces 8,5%
des cancers sont dus au travail chez les
ouvriers ce sont 20% des cancers qui
sont liés voilà donc il faut tenir
compte de ces inégalités de santé de
l'allongement de la réforme
un amendement 4310
[Musique]
mes chers collègues d'abord
permettez-moi de
donner des bons des mauvais points mais
je voulais remercier les 101 sénateurs
et sénatrices qui ont voté un peu plus
d'espérance de vie pour les égoutiers
voilà parce que c'est bien qu'ici au
Parlement il y a une liberté de vote et
qui fasse que et oui et oui qui est pas
que la gauche qui est donnée un peu plus
d'espérance de vie aux égoutiers cela
étant dit cela étant dit j'en viens
l'amendement sur le président sous votre
Haute autorité et leur là évidemment
comment vous dire
bah c'est un manquement il est au cœur
de tout le débat qu'on a sur l'article 7
c'est que un moment propose que nous
n'appliquons pas les deux années
supplémentaires pour la sanction
publique hospitalière voilà donc faut
avoir le netteté de le dire ça va ça
fait débat et je voudrais vous dire que
et pour revisiter une explication de
vote
en ce qui concerne les élus communistes
du point de vue des fonctionnaires de la
fonction publique hospitalière nous
sommes pour un retour départ à 60 ans je
vous le dis
une prise en compte des années d'études
dans le calcul de leur retraite et
troisièmement
une indexation des pensions sur les sur
les salaires et puis ça a été peut-être
un peu à d'autres moments dans notre
débat monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres et Messieurs mes collègues
enfin je me rappelle la loi de finances
je me rappelle il y a eu quand même 150
milliards de fer au patronat donc je me
dis pour la fonction publique
hospitalière et pour d'autres
10 15 milliards au regard de 150
milliards offerts par exemple ça aurait
mériter un examen plus équilibré plus
juste voilà je vous remercie pour votre
attention alors la vie la vie de la
commission
madame la rapporteur général monsieur le
rapporteur
un avis un avis défavorable bien entendu
et puis également pour
l'amendement parce que là la roneéo elle
est encore tournée alors monsieur le
ministre
oui défavorable également trois
remarques monsieur le sénateur d'abord
la fonction publique hospitalière c'est
celle où il y a le plus de catégories
actives 350 000 agents catégories actifs
dans la fonction publique hospitalière
et donc tous les dispositifs qui
apportent des dispositifs de réparation
supplémentaires par rapport aux autres
agents concerne davantage la fonction
publique hospitalière deuxième argument
c'est la fonction publique dans lequel
l'amélioration que j'ai pu décrire tout
à l'heure sur les contrat actuels qui
seront titularisés et la plus effective
je pense un peu plus de 100000
aide-soignants qui font le même travail
que les 200 000 aides soignants qui sont
catégoractives et qui verront leurs
années de service comptabilisés à
l'occasion de leur titularisation et
puis troisième argument celui de la
prévention je sais que c'est pas
l'argument qui vous convainc aujourd'hui
mais je le donne comme un élément de
complément
et en donnant un argument de périmètre
au fond parce que le fonds de prévention
que nous allons créer dédié au métier du
soin un de mes milliard d'euros sur le
quinquennat un demi milliard d'euros sur
le quinquennat nous allons le concentrer
sur les établissements hospitaliers et
les établissements médico-sociaux et
c'est là où je pense que pendre
simplement le périmètre de la fonction
hospitalière c'est limité d'une certaine
façon parce que il y a des agents qui
sont dans des établissements
médico-sociaux qui font partie de la
fonction Puy du territoriale et que en
prenant une périmètre de la fonction
publique hospitalière vous ne couvrirez
pas et donc pour cette raison là la vie
est défavorable merci explication de
vote
j'avais cru que vous monsieur le
Président juste une chose à travers la
fonction publique hospitalière est-ce
que vous venez de dire mais sur d'autres
professions franchement
toute réforme doit être un progrès de
société pour tout le monde
et je pense que nous aurions dû nous
autoriser à élargir le débat
parlementaire autour de nouveaux
critères de pénibilité voilà je pense
franchement et c'est au cœur y compris
de la fonction hospitalière et de ce que
nous disent beaucoup des agents de la
fonction hospitalière
alors je demande de scrutin public
le scrutin public
est ouvert
[Musique]
344 pour 100 contre 244 Sénat n'a pas
adopté
4318 monsieur gay le présente
merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est un
amendement qui va satisfaire le
gouvernement et Monsieur le Ministre
puisque l'amendement nous venons de
présenter vous faisez pas totalement
puisqu'il s'adressait qu'à la fonction
hospitalière et celui-là mais c'est le
même mais pour tous les fonctionnaires
donc vous voyez on est là là on est on y
est non mais juste dans la même veine on
regrette qu'un certain nombre
d'amendements n'ont pas été jugés
recevable j'entends que monsieur le
rapporteur dit la renéo a tourné mais ce
que dit Pascal il a entièrement raison
c'est qu'on aurait dû débattre
aujourd'hui des nouvelles conditions de
travail et des nouveaux métiers où il y
a beaucoup de pénibilité par exemple un
travail que fait Pascal avec d'autres
sur les livreurs et livreuses on n'avait
pas ça il y a 40 ans mais aujourd'hui
c'est une nouvelle difficulté pour
beaucoup de travailleuses et
travailleurs prenons les entrepôts
Amazon qui s'installe partout sur nos
territoires et souvent ici on a le débat
sur les centres-villes les centres
bourre le commerce qui est tué par ces
grandes entrepôts il y a déjà des études
qui sortent pour les travailleurs et les
travailleuses qui sont dans ces
entrepôts qui ne voient pas le jour
pendant plusieurs heures qui travaillent
à la chaîne c'est des nouvelles
difficultés des nouvelles pénibilités
sauf que comme on n'a pas pu aller au
bout d'un certain nombre d'amendements
sur la question des métiers et c'était
pas pour faire du son stéréo c'était
pour dire que oui il y a beaucoup de
métiers où il y a des difficultés et il
faudra prendre en compte cela notamment
sur leurs conditions de travail leurs
conditions de salaire mais aussi sur des
départs anticipés à la retraite donc
voilà Monsieur Yanni vous avez de la
chance on a répondu par l'affirmatif à
votre demande
alors monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président j'ai
l'impression que son entrepôt d'Amazon
de chez vous a été nationalisé puisque
là c'est un amendement qui concerne les
trimestres cotisées pour les
fonctionnaires de catégorie actifs donc
avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre mais la vie
monsieur
alors je consulte une demande de scrutin
public
scrutin ouvert
parce que
là je crois alors tu reçois de la salle
de presse et au lieu d'aller vers
autant 345 exprimé 344 pour 94 contre
250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
et nous pensons à l'amendement 3600
3609 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président des alliés
monsieur le rapporteur faut pas éteindre
la René
sur ce ça aurait été peut-être plus
facile si on avait disposé d'une
véritable étude d'impact de cette
réforme et notamment de l'article 7 on
aurait dû le demander au Conseil d'État
en même temps que vous savez la note là
on en reparle donc on aurait eu les deux
notes parce qu'il y a un point aveugle à
ce à cette réforme
on sait que les ouvriers et les employés
qualifiés comme non qualifiés vont être
vraiment les très très grands perdants
de cette réforme et il y a aussi un
impact du coup sur les personnes qui
sont le sur- représentés dans ces
métiers je veux parler des personnes
immigrées
selon l'observateur des inégalités les
postes s'occuper par les émigrés sont
souvent les emplois qui n'ont pas été
acceptés par les autres du fait des
conditions de travail de rémunération
sécurité nettoyage bâtiment restauration
beaucoup sont des métiers essentiels au
fonctionnement de l'économie et de la
société française
l'étude de la DARES montre que un emploi
sur dix est occupé par un immigré mais
que parmi l'ensemble des 87 familles
professionnelles 35 métiers se
distinguent par une proportion
supérieure et ses professions ce sont
celles qui sont exposées à des
conditions de travail contraignantes ou
à des tensions bien sûr sur le marché du
travail des métiers particulièrement
exposés au risque d'accident du travail
d'épuisement de détérioration de la
santé 35 métiers où les immigrés sont
sur représentés donc qui se
caractérisent par des conditions de
travail plus contraignantes il y a des
contraintes physiques des limitations
physiques des contraintes doriques du
travail répétitif des périodes de
travail durant les jours non ouvrables
ou en dehors des plages de travail
habituel un morcellement des journées de
travail vous avez repéré tous les
critères de pénibilité qui d'ailleurs
devrait être enrichi
c'est fini alors voilà je vous remercie
alors la vidéo monsieur le rapporteur
merci Madame Raymond de possémant je
crois que là vous êtes carrément trompé
de texte dans vos explications de vote
parce que le texte immigration va pas
tarder à venir mais par contre l'objet
de l'abonnement est intéressant puisque
vous proposez de laisser à 62 ans et
surtout pas à 64 ans les les maîtres
d'établissement d'enseignement privé
sous contrat
je ne connaissais pas votre attachement
à l'école privée je la découvre je vous
en félicite donc avis défavorable
[Applaudissements]
je vais consulter
ce qui suivent cet amendement le
manifestant devant la main
je sens plus de maîtrise des mains avis
contraire
il n'est pas adopté et nous passons à
l'amendement 3610
madame pour ces Monge
c'est celui qui est
défendu il est défendu
il est défendu
invite la Commission
défavorable de la commission de même le
gouvernement je consulte ceux qui sont
favorables manifestants devant la main
avis contraire n'est pas adopté et nous
passons en 3600 12
de suppressions
rapporteur que les travailleurs du privé
comme les travailleurs du public font
l'objet de toute notre attention
consultez je voudrais la revenir sur un
autre un autre avis sur cette cette
réforme et sur l'article 7 le conseil de
la Caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie qui a émis quand même il
faudrait longtemps un avis défavorable
selon cette caisse une grande loi
autonomie bon s’avait nécessaire on le
sait on nous l'a promise on l'a toujours
pas mais c'est très défavorable pour les
personnes c'est très fort en situation
de handicap et de leurs proches pour les
prochaines années
je reviens pas sur l'accélération du
vieillissement qui est concomitante du
peu de progrès pour prévenir la perte de
d'autonomie car si l'espérance de vie
augmente l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé ne connaît que des évolutions
désormais modestes selon l'INSEE en 2050
pourtant 4 millions de seniors seront en
situation de perte d'autonomie de plus
selon une étude de menée par
l'Observatoire Everest spécialisé dans
l'étude des évolutions et santé au
travail après 60 ans voilà le lien après
60 ans la moitié des ouvriers des
employés doutent que leur état de santé
leur permettent à horizon de deux ans de
poursuivre leur travail actuel quel sera
ce sondage quand on leur demandera d'y
aller d'aller jusqu'à 4 ans de plus et
on sait que d'autres travaux
scientifiques par ces confirme ses
doutes il s'en fondait il laisse
présager la survenue d'incapacité dans
son avis motivé donc le Conseil souhaite
alerter sur l'impact potentiel d'un
allongement de la durée du travail sur
l'équilibre des eaux de branches en
particulier pour les professions
présentant un niveau élevé de pénibilité
si cette dernière n'était insuffisamment
prise en compte
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
alors l'avis de la commission sur le
rapporteur
je vous sens impatiente de parler de
santé au travail c'est l'article 9 j'ai
pas l'impression qu'à travers ses
amendements vous soyez vraiment
réellement pressé d'y arriver c'est un
moment concerne lui et le remboursement
des trimestres rejetés comme vous l'avez
bien compris dans les explications de
vote donc avis défavorable merci la vie
de gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président oui il se
trouve je crois madame la sénatrice que
vous avez voté avec tout le monde le
fait de faciliter le rachat des
trimestres pour l'apprentissage pour les
stages pour les études si on a d'autres
peut-être votre abonnement plus personne
ne peut racheter trimestre puisque vous
supprimez le dispositif de rachat
avis défavorable
il est retiré
[Musique]
à 3614 monsieur dessus oui merci
monsieur le Président on arrive à la fin
de cet article 7
parmi les défenseurs de cette réforme on
a pu lire le soutien d'Elon musk au
départ moi je me suis mis un peu
interrogé pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'il en
avait à faire de de cette réforme et
puis en fait on comprend assez vite
puisqu'elle correspond assez bien à sa
vision du monde puisque avec cette
réforme évidemment les inégalités déjà
criantes vont s'aggraver
quelques seniors multimillionnaires et
tant d'autres
sans emploi et sans retraite plusieurs
grands patrons du CAC 40 ont repris leur
retraite ces derniers mois ils ont tous
cédé les reines alors de leur entreprise
en 2021 ou 2022 ainsi que la direction
opérationnelle de leur groupe tout en
restant au moins provisoirement
président du Conseil administration
c'est néo retraités ont eu la liberté de
choisir quand il partira à la retraite
dans quelles conditions et par qui il
serait remplacé
en parallèle la présenterait forme des
retraites va maintenir des milliers de
personnes supplémentaires dans le sas de
précarité sans emploi ni retraite
l'adresse relever en 2020 que le taux de
pauvreté des personnes ni en emploi ni
en retraite de 53 à 69 ans était de 32%
de plus en 2018 le taux de pauvreté des
personnes de 65 ans ou plus or personne
vivant en institution était de 8,6% plus
d'un million de personnes pauvres cette
réforme va aggraver ces inégalités il
faut la retirer je vous remercie
merci
avis de la commission
merci sont des dispositions très
intéressantes madame poncemont je
puisque vous parlez de
la prise en compte des
des temps de travail acquis et qui
pourraient être ensuite redéplacer
quand vous avez une titularisation c'est
dommage de vouloir supprimer cela
c'était une avancée sociale tout à fait
significative vous nous proposez de la
supprimer en vous comprenez qu'on donne
un avis défavorable
alors je suis le ministre le même avis
défavorable ce qui sont favorables
manifestants devant la main
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté nous pensons
d'amendement 3615
qui le présente
il est défendu
je consulte ceux qui sont alors l'avis
de la commission pardonnez-moi
vaut mieux le retirer celui-là celui-là
aussi monsieur le Président vaut mieux
le retirer vous souhaitez un retrait
il est retiré
le 3617 madame ponce à Madame Vogel
on arrive donc là maintenant
véritablement à la fin de l'article 7 et
je voudrais en profiter pour appeler
quelques informations selon le rapport
sur les objectifs de la réforme remis
par le gouvernement le déficit serait de
12 milliards d'euros en 2027 et de 13,5
milliards en 2030 la fatalité présumée
de ce déficit dont le corps estime qu'il
ne provient pas d'une dérive des
dépenses conduit les autorités à
prescrire un report de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits à la retraite à 64 ans et une
accélération du calendrier de la réforme
Touraine pourtant selon le corps
lui-même le problème du système des
retraites provient du fait de
l'insuffisance de la trajectoire des
ressources un ensemble de mesures plus
juste moins brutal ont été présentés
pour financer différemment notre système
de retraite augmenter le nombre de
fonctionnaires augmenter les cotisations
selon le corps une augmentation de 0,8
points de cotisation d'ici 2027
suffirait à elle seule à combler le
déficit attendu cela correspondrait à 28
euros par mois pour le salaire moyen
sachant que selon le corps le salaire
moyen devrait augmenter de 128 euros
d'ici 2027 l'augmentation du taux de
cotisation salariale et possible sans
impacter le pouvoir d'achat on peut
aussi augmenter les salaires ce qui
augmente automatiquement les cotisations
sociales on peut en finir avec les
politiques d'exonération
inutile et
inefficace on peut aussi revoir le
calendrier de remboursement de la CADES
vous avez refusé l'intégralité de ces
mesures néanmoins ce sont les seuls qui
permettraient de financer notre système
des retraites de façon juste efficace
sans faire trimer les plus précaires
deux ans de plus vous allez me dire
monsieur le ministre ça n'a rien à voir
avec la linea que vous supprimez en
l'occurrence c'est pas vraiment le cas
puisque c'est le dernier alinéa qui
stipule quand l'article va s'appliquer
nous souhaiterions que cet article ne
s'applique jamais
monsieur le rapporteur
merci merci c'était tu as fait ça vous
souhaitez effectivement décaler cette
réforme donc il y aurait plus d'impact
sur 2023 et en conséquence dans le cadre
de ce PLFSS ce serait
anticonstitutionnel vous avez retrouvé
votre finesse d'esprit pour proposer un
amendement que bien sûr avis défavorable
le ministre même avis je consulte ceux
qui sont favorables le manifestant
devant la main
à vie contraire
il n'est pas adopté
je voudrais former
le Sénat que l'amendement déposé par
notre collègue l'homme arrive sur le
numéro
233 a été retiré
en conséquence
les amendements numéro
4865 tombe
[Applaudissements]
nous allons donc passer au vote sur
l'article 7
je vous indique d'ores et déjà que j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe CRCE
en application de l'article 42 alinéa 10
de notre règlement il conformément la
décision de la Conférence des Présidents
lors de sa réunion de ce mercredi 8 mars
je vous rappelle que les prises de
parole explication de vote sur chaque
article de ce projet de loi sont limités
à un seul orateur par groupe politique
et un seul sénateur
ne figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
pour une durée de 2 minutes je vais donc
donner la parole à un orateur par Madame
j'ai vu madame la Présidente assassin
levait la main
merci monsieur le Président donc la
droite sénatoriale la majorité du Sénat
avec la complicité du gouvernement a
perdu son sang-froid comme je l'ai dit
hier soir sur cet article 7 ensemble
vous ne supportez plus l'exercice
pleinement constitutionnel du droit
d'amendement de sous-amendements et de
l'expression des parlementaires pour sa
part la droite sénatoriale menée par
Monsieur Retailleau nouveau ministre
chargé des Relations avec le Parlement
et madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales et les rapporteurs
ont violé le règlement du Sénat en
déclarant irrecevable des abonnements
qui étaient pourtant pleinement sur cet
article 7
toutes toutes les procédures possibles
et imaginables ont été dégainées par
plusieurs présidents de groupe
favorables à cet article 7 sais-je le
redis la démonstration d'un coup de
force monsieur le Président vous vous
êtes assis sur votre propre règlement et
la prétendue sagesse du Sénat on a pris
un coup c'est une ligne rouge qui a été
franchie elle porte gravement atteinte
aux principes constitutionnels de clarté
et de sincérité des débats votre
objectif c'est de s'assurer l'opposition
à ce projet d'allongement de l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 74 à 64 ans au
cœur de l'article 7 vous avez agi de la
sorte au soir même d'une magnifique
mobilisation du peuple qui ne veut pas
subir deux années de travail
supplémentaires avec le gouvernement
vous tentez d'imposer ce dogme libéral
celui qui prend toujours plus au plus
pauvre pour donner toujours plus au plus
riche avec vos procédures vous avez
empêché la discussion de nos
propositions
celle qui vise à renforcer la
participation des revenus des plus aisés
et financiers au financement du régime
de retraite vous n'avez pas voulu
protégeant actionnaires et patronat de
ce débat essentiel sur le partage des
richesses vous battez le débat pour
dissimuler la vérité à nos concitoyens
parmi lesquels vos propres électeurs qui
sont aussi dans la mobilisation à votre
grande âme évidemment monsieur le
Président nous voterons nous voter cet
article 7
issu de la corps scellé entre le
gouvernement et la majorité de droite
sénatoriale
Monsieur Olivier Hainaut
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres
majoritairement et sans surprise nous
voterons cet article 7 nous inventons
cette article 7 et les rapporteurs tout
au long de ce débat l'ont démontré parce
que nous avons la conviction que nous
sauvons le système de retraite par
répartition nous lui donnons un avenir
mes chers collègues oui c'est bien ça
que nous faisons
nous votons cette article 7 parce que
nous pensons et c'est un clivage entre
nous que nous avons la responsabilité
oui la responsabilité d'aller au bout de
ce texte nous avons cette responsabilité
par rapport au système par répartition
mais nous avons aussi cette
responsabilité par rapport et je vous
réponds par rapport à la crédibilité et
l'image du Sénat par rapport à la
crédibilité et l'image de la démocratie
représentative car que deviendrait la
démocratie représentative si ni
l'assemblée et ni le Sénat ne se
prononcer sur un texte aussi essentiel
un dernier mot sur les les arguments
alors
vous avez travaillé je dirais même que
si c'était à la quantité de salive et
d'encre il faudrait donner le maillot
jaune à Madame ponce
j'ai tout entendu deux enfermes comme si
le travail était une prison mais que
quelle vision triste de la société voler
deux ans
mais en même temps voyez-vous je pense
que je n'arrive pas à croire notamment
ceux qui ont voté la réforme Touraine
que il y ait beaucoup de sincérité dans
vos arguments vous découvrez que le
système de retraite est parfois injuste
mais pourquoi ne l'avez vous pas
découvert lorsque vous abordiez la
réforme Touraine bon sang et puis je
finir comme j'en ai l'habitude par deux
citations au fond c'est vos intérêts
électoraux que vous dépendez
l'hypocrisie c'était Balzac qui disait
ça l'hypocrisie n'est rien de plus qu'un
hommage à l'intérêt vos intérêts
électoraux et donc nous nous le
choisissons pas l'hypocrisie nous
choisissons la responsabilité la
responsabilité c'est le prix à payer du
succès disait Churchill je vous remercie
madame Lubin
mes chers collègues nous venons de
passer d'une minute de quelques secondes
la date du 8 mars l'histoire retiendra à
Monsieur du soft
que votre nom et votre nom monsieur du
monsieur le ministre du soft restera à
jamais attaché restera à jamais attaché
à celui d'une réforme qui fera revenir
presque
40 ans en arrière
oui oui presque 40 ans en arrière et
franchement j'espère quand votre fort
intérieur ça vous parle et ça ne vous
fait pas particulièrement plaisir et
surtout l'histoire retiendra quand ce 8
mars 2023 nous aurons nous aurons voté
vous aurez voté un projet de loi qui
fera travailler les salariés les plus
modestes ceux qui travaillent déjà
depuis longtemps ceux qui ont les
salaires les plus modestes ceux qui ont
les emploie les produits difficiles et
dans lesquels nous trouvons une grande
majorité de femmes
histoire retiendra que c'est quasiment 8
mars que vous aurez fait voter ce texte
là alors non nous ne sommes pas des
irresponsables non nous ne sommes pas
des irresponsables le rapport du corps
nous le connaissons nous sommes
quelques-uns ici à le connaître bien
plus que vous tous ici rassembler pour
l'instant pour l'instant à ce jour à ce
jour à ce jour il n'y a pas de déficit
et oui il y a des projections qui
donnent peut-être peut-être un déficit
de 13 milliards d'euros sur
360 milliards d'euros de retraite qui
sont payés tous les ans alors oui alors
oui nous disons nous disons qu'il faut
effectivement
s'intéresser à l'avenir de nos retraites
mais nous avons développé aussi qu'il y
avait tout un tas d'autres solutions
histoire retiendra que vous vous faites
payer les ouvriers les salariés les gens
les plus modestes de ce pays
monsieur lévrier pour le gros père des
pays
merci monsieur le Président le constat
du corps éclaire nous devions le prendre
à bras le corps le déficit structurel de
notre système de retraite existe et sur
le long terme et très terriblement
dangereux pour notre système et pour la
protection des retraités oui l'article 7
demande un effort aux Français il n'est
pas question de le nier oui cet effort
est indispensable et il est
indispensable en particulier pour les
jeunes et je suis très étonné que dans
cette hémicycle nous ayons quasiment
jamais aborder les jeunes je regrette
aussi toujours que les gens qui sont à
ma droite et ce besoin systématique de
parler quand les autres ont la parole
c'est assez pénible et cet effort est
vraiment et moi je veux parler à notre
jeunesse et leur dire qu'à travers cet
effort que nous demandons à tous c'est
pour eux que nous le faisons pour que
dans 30 ans quand ils seront un peu
moins jeunes ils se disent oui notre
système de retraite fonctionne oui le
système para répartition est un système
fort qui nous protège et qui protégera
plus tard la jeunesse je me réjouis que
ce vote permette aussi le débat qui a lu
et permettre surtout de continuer le
travail sur les articles qui vont
arriver et qui sont les articles vous
les avez tous lu vous êtes
extraordinaire
cet article les articles suivants qui
sont les articles qui protègent qui
protègent je le redis et en particulier
les plus fragiles enfin je voudrais
rappeler que nous sommes le Parlement
que nous représentons les Français et
qu'il est de notre devoir de voter
l'ensemble de ce texte nous sommes
attendus sur ce sujet et nous devons
être à la hauteur je vous remercie
d'inscris monsieur le Président
Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
3 3 remarques
trois remarques
en guise explications de vote la
première une nouvelle preuve ce soir une
nouvelle preuve d'obstruction les 90
sous amendements de Madame Hubin qui
décale d'une journée la remise d'un
rapport ça n'est pas mesdames messieurs
de l'obstruction vous êtes en train de
vous
mélenchoniser jamais nous accepterons
que vous mélangiez le Sénat
l'obstruction ça n'est pas la démocratie
parlementaire c'est le Parlement qui se
fait Hara-Kiri c'est un 49,3 à l'envers
la deuxième
observation
c'est l'hypocrisie les donneurs de
leçons vous qui n'avez pas brochet vous
qui n'est pas abrogé justement le
décalage d'âge de 2010 vous l'avez
empiré avec la loi Touraine 43 à nuités
aujourd'hui c'est 65 ans c'est là la
réalité et ça il faut le dire aux
Français et enfin bien sûr que nous
allons bien sûr nous allons voter cet
article 7 vous espériez qu'on ne le vote
pas ce soir nous le voterons ce soir
vous le voterons parce que il va
permettre de sauver le régime de
retraite par répartition bien sûr bien
sûr c'est un levier budgétaire mais ceux
qui se moquent des chiffres se moquent
des gens derrière les chiffres il y a
les déficits derrière les déficit il y a
l'argent des Français derrière l'argent
des Français il y a la peine des
Français et puis et puis la limite d'âge
justement est protectrice rel la fameuse
étude de la CNAV elle avait comment
dirais-je comparer une simuler une
simulation deux hypothèses première
hypothèse uniquement repousser les
annuités 300 euros en moins de retraites
par an elle avait comparé l'autre
hypothèse un relèvement justement de la
durée légale le gain c'était 300 euros
en moyenne et bien vous savez cette
bande d'âge est protectrice c'est un
filet de sécurité et nous le voterons
dès ce soir
d'autres demandent de groupe voilà pour
ces manches
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président moi je suis
désolé quand même que vous nous
contraignez à une seule personne parce
qu'il y a un impact dont on n'a pas
parlé c'est l'impact sur les inégalités
territoriales les manifestations elles
ont été exceptionnelles aussi dans le
monde rural vous devriez le savoir moi
ce que je souhaiterais dire un petit peu
c'est que vous connaissez les effets de
la réforme de 2017 vous les connaissez
ce sera les mêmes aggravé pour la
réforme que vous vous apprêtez à voter
ce que je veux dire aussi c'est que
l'article 7 c'est l'article dont le
gouvernement dit qu'il est non
négociable c'est le seul article que
vous voulez effectivement que les
syndicats voulaient qu'on discute et
longuement hier il nous restait cinq
jours vous avez sabré se disait cet
article donc ne vous réclamez pas des
syndicats pour ce qui est de 2010 on les
connaît les effets l'effet dominant de
la réforme a été de figer des situations
atteintes à l'approche de la soixantaine
dans la teinte d'un nouvel âge c'est le
fameux changement de deux ans du
précarité c'est chez les ouvriers la
hausse de la précarité on vous l'a dit
pour les femmes nous en avons parlé
c'est la durée de la retraite qui a
diminué d'un an et qui va diminuer
encore de plus d'un an car ce n'est plus
l'allongement ce n'est plus permis par
la longement de la durée de vie on ne
travaille pas plus longtemps parce qu'on
vit plus longtemps vous allez nous faire
travailler plus longtemps parce qu'on va
rester moins longtemps à la retraite
c'est une augmentation on l'a dit des
personnes au minima et surtout c'est un
effet c'est un une atténuation de
l'effet de l'effet redistributif de la
retraite les effets les effets ont été
antirodistributifs et ils vont l'être un
peu plus donc oui voilà les
enseignements 2010 nous disent que cette
réforme est injustifiée elle est
inégalitaire elle est productiviste et
nous en reparlerons et c'est pour ça
messieurs qu'elle est impopulaire et
c'est pour ça que il suffira pas de la
voter
les le mouvement social continuera
jusqu'à son retrait
bien
mais pas d'autres demandes et maintenant
de groupes je vais maintenant passer au
scrutin public
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 sur l'ensemble de l'article 7
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scooter est Claude
votant 345 exprimé 316 pour 201 contre
115 le Sénat a adopté l'article 7
[Applaudissements]
nous allons passer après l'article 7 à
des articles additionnels avec tout
d'abord cette amendement
identique
un amendement présenté 136 points caisse
qui le présente
monsieur Burgoa
défendu
un amendement 226 rectifiés monsieur
Dupont il est défendu
il n'est pas défendu un amendement
présenté par Monsieur sol 238 rectifié
n'est pas défendu madame la un
amendement présenté par
madame Delattre
n'est pas défendu un amendement présenté
par le président kaner je vais le
défendre monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur les ministres c'est
un amendement qui concerne les
directeurs départementaux qui sont très
précieux vous le savez au sein des
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels ils
dirigent les corps des sapeurs-pompiers
sur le plan technique administratif
opérationnel ce sont aussi les
partenaires privilégiés des préfets qui
sont de fait leur patron cet amendement
vise à ce que nos combattants du feu
quel que soit l'emploi qu'ils occupent
peut-être classés comme catégorie active
car le caractère dangereux de ce métier
des missions qui sont assignées à ces
agents publics et reconnus par la
sécurité civile vous le savez les
pompiers partenaires de cette sécurité
civile font face à de nouveaux enjeux et
notamment y compris le réchauffement
climatique et je voudrais à nouveau
comme nous l'avons fait à plusieurs
reprises cet été salués leur
extraordinaire leur extraordinaire
engagement notamment dans les feux de
Gironde pour cela nous avons besoin de
recrutement nous avons besoin de
susciter des vocations mes chers
collègues et donc nous avons besoin de
fidéliser or il dispose d'un régime
favorable s'il dispose d'un régime
favorable pour compenser leurs
conditions de travail qui sont
difficiles ce régime est justifié si on
souhaite prendre en compte la pénibilité
au vu des horaires décalés des
contraintes physiques inhérentes à la
profession des sapeurs-pompiers quel que
soit le métier exercer au sein de ce
corps c'est le sens de cet amendement
que j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter
merci amendement monsieur Standon
merci monsieur le Président je suis
ministre
je suis un collègue l'ensemble des
saveurs pompiers professionnels
attendent de nous l'écriture d'une
nouvelle page
[Musique]
la commission monsieur le rapporteur sur
ces deux amendements
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement
il est proposé de maintenir à 57 ans
l'âge d'ouverture des droits applicables
au sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels hors la loi propose de
reporter cet âge à 59 ans comme les
autres
catégories
il est important nous semble-t-il de
maintenir un écart de 5 ans par rapport
à l'âge de droit commun c'est la raison
pour laquelle c'est la répartition de
l'effort la commission juge nécessaire
que chacun contribue à l'effort de
redressement de la trajectoire
financière de notre système de retraite
et je rappelle qu'en revanche la durée
de service effective requise pour
bénéficier de ce type de départ anticipé
reste bien toujours fixé à 17 ans donc
avis défavorable ou retrait mes chers
collègues merci
donc
la vie est défavorable
je consulte ceux qui sont favorables
l'adoption de l'amendement tout d'abord
23 17 rectifiés manifeste en devant la
main
ceux qui sont favorables à demande de
scrutin public pardonnez
le public
le temps simplement de l'enregistrer
dans sa nécessite un peu de temps
public est ouvert
345 exprimé 341 pour 103 compte 238 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté et nous allons
examiner après l'article 7 un article
additionnel avec un amendement qui a 9
sous amendements un amendement
4409 rectifié bis madame ma poursu poli
madame Cohen le présente
merci monsieur le Président notre
amendement fait la proposition de
revaloriser les pensions de retraite en
fonction de l'évolution du salaire moyen
afin de garantir dans le temps le taux
de remplacement à 75% des derniers
salaires les projections du corps
montrent que les pensions des retraites
décrocheront par rapport aux revenus des
actifs dans les prochaines années en
raison de l'indexation des retraites sur
les prix qui est moins favorable que
l'indexation sur les salaires vous le
savez mes chers collègues la perte du
pouvoir d'achat et le premier sujet de
préoccupation des Françaises et des
Français en un an les produits
alimentaires ont augmenté de 15% environ
et après les négociations entre les
grandes surfaces et leurs fournisseurs
ils devraient encore augmenter de 10%
environ donc cette mesure est pour nous
une mesure de justice sociale elle fait
elle fait elle fait d'ailleurs partie
d'une proposition de loi que nous avons
déposée au niveau de mon groupe le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste il y a un an visant à mettre
en place 50 mesures pour un véritable
bouclier social donc voilà le sens de
notre amendement je vous remercie merci
alors insoum amendement qui porte le
numéro
4874 qui le présente Madame Lubin
c'est un amendement qui vient
sous amender celui de nos de nos
collègues du CRCE et qui viennent en
soutien en fait
nous savons que une de une des mesures
qui a fortement contribué à faire
baisser ou du moins à
interdire une certaine évolution des
pensions de retraite c'est que elle soit
indexée sur le sur les prix et non plus
sur les salaires et donc cet amendement
du CRCE propose que les pensions de
retraite soit revalorisées chaque année
en fonction de l'évolution du salaire
moyen et nous nous jouons avec cet
amende de ces sous amendements nous
jouons sur les dates parce qu'il nous
paraît effectivement que pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français des retraités et
des futurs retraités c'est une mesure
importante
merci
ensuite
le sous amendement
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président donc on
vient de voter l'article 7 et comme je
sais que vous n'aimez pas en général les
témoignages je vais vous en faire
plusieurs parce qu'en plus on vient de
clôturer la journée du 8 mars et vous
n'aimez pas les témoignages je le sais
c'est normal ça vous met très mal à
l'aise parce qu'en fait ça vous renvoie
la brutalité de votre réforme en pleine
face je prends l'exemple de Michel
gouvernante dans l'hôtellerie à force de
tenir le balai la journée j'ai des
fourmis dans les mains la nuit ce métier
il est pénible on arrive même pas à
tenir jusqu'à 60 ans Alors 64
Mado femme de ménage mais genou me font
trop mal si j'essaie de me baisser je
n'y arrive pas non plus on est dans
l'ombre mais on est partout si vous
allez à l'hôtel ce que vous faites
souvent et que vous dormez dans un lit
bien fait c'est grâce à nous si votre
bureau est propre quand vous quand vous
arrivez le matin c'est grâce à nous mais
personne ne nous voit Ingrid conductrice
de RER on a l'impression que le
gouvernement se fiche de ces
manifestations qu'il s'en foutent de
nous qu'ils sont dans un autre monde Je
vous confirme que ce soir vous êtes dans
un autre monde dans un autre monde qui
pendant des jours et des jours des
semaines et des semaines des gens ont
manifesté vous ne les entendez pas vous
êtes sur votre planète vous n'entendez
pas la majorité des Français vous
n'entendez pas la majorité de votre
propre électorat qui vous le fera payer
très cher je l'espère d'ailleurs aux
prochaines élections pour cette réforme
injuste vous le paierez dans les urnes
parce que tout injustice se fait tôt ou
tard et là et l'article de l'injustice
que vous avez voté vous le paierez au
comptant parce que vous c'est des vies
que vous allez brutaliser et ça c'est
inacceptable vous avez brutalisé le
Parlement déjà hier à travers ce que
vous avez fait cette nuit et vous
brutalisez avec le vote de cet article 7
des millions de gens qui vous le feront
payer dans les urnes merci
4867 qui le déforme chez Durin merci
monsieur le Président
nos collègues communistes ont le souci
de garantir dans le temps le taux de
remplacement à 75% des derniers salaires
ils ont soucis d'éviter un décrochage on
sait et on connaît la sensibilité de nos
compatriotes à l'inflation et les
difficultés qu'un grand nombre d'entre
eux rencontre dans la période où les
prix explosent et un certain nombre
d'entre eux sont en l'état actuel des
choses et de la loi promis à un
électable érosion de leur pension de
retraite et partant de leur niveau de
vie notre sous amendement vient donc en
soutien de cet amendement du groupe CRCR
et propose d'ajuster la date de prise
d'effet de la revalorisation pour
garantir ce taux de remplacement
un abonnement
4870 monsieur hulgate
sur le Président Monsieur monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues connaissait
la méthode évitez réduire compensée
éviter donc n'avons pas pu éviter donc
le vote de cet article 7 pourtant c'est
dommage on n'a pas eu l'occasion de
discuter sur l'amendement de Monsieur
van laurenberg parce que c'est un
amendement qui est extrêmement
intéressant
il est intéressant parce que c'est une
situation peu commune dans la mesure où
vous avez quelqu'un qui soutient la
majorité présidentielle qui proposait il
la retiré je le conçois il proposait
tout simplement un rapport mais ce
rapport il avait pour objectif de revoir
l'évolution des paramètres pour assurer
l'équilibre financier parce que il y a
un doute sur l'équilibre financier de la
de la réforme telle qu'elle est proposée
à l'heure actuelle il proposait et là
c'est extrêmement cocasse il proposait
alors que justement l'argument c'est de
sauver le de répartition que les
conditions et voix d'évolution de notre
système de retraite vers un régime
universel par point soit proposé donc il
proposait en quelque sorte de revenir à
la case départ d'il y a quelques
quelques mois et puis également il
prévoyait d'assurer l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes donc si il y a demande de
précision et de rapport ça veut dire
qu'il y a qu'il y a un doute évitez nous
ne l'avons pas pu par contre ce que nous
pouvons d'une certaine façon c'est de
réduire les impacts et de réduire les
impacts c'est d'apporter des garanties
et l'amendement de nos collègues du CRCE
justement il apporte une garantie sur le
fait que le taux de remplacement se
limite à 75% et ça me semble moi
extrêmement juste alors ensuite nos sous
amendements donc ils sont par rapport à
des dates et je n'en dirai pas plus mais
tout simplement nous sommes donc dans la
démarche à l'heure actuelle puisque nous
n'avons pas pu éviter c'est d'essayer de
réduire l'impact de cette réforme qui
est néfaste et puis après nous
essaierons de voir comment compenser
merci d'amendement 4868
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues ce sous amendement pour
soutenir l'amendement présenté par notre
collègue Présidente assassy c'est
amendement il a pour but de rentrer
votre réforme un peu moins désespérante
pour les Français parce qu'elle est
désespérante depuis 2017 il y a eu des
cadeaux fiscaux pour les détenteurs du
capital pour les grandes entreprises qui
devaient entraîner un effet de
ruissellement dont bénéficierait les
Français conclusion 6 ans après vous
leur demandez un impôt sur la vie de
deux ans pour rembourser l'ensemble des
efforts qui ont été faits au bénéfice de
ceux qui n'en n'avaient pas besoin alors
cet amendement il a pour but d'éviter au
moins une double peine qu'il n'y ait pas
à la fois une mesure d'âge très
désespérante et en plus un niveau de
pension insuffisant puisque vous avez
voté l'article 7 qui recule de deux ans
l'âge et bien au moins garantissez un
meilleur niveau de retraite à chacun je
crois que c'était pour cela que vous
votiez justement cet article 7 c'est
l'occasion de le prouver maintenant
4871 qui le défend sur le président
kaner non
il est défendu
il est
sous amendement 4869
que le peuple
dans les années 80 les personnes de plus
de 65 ans
n'ont plus été les personnes qui ont été
le plus sous le seuil de pauvreté en
France et c'est grâce à notre système de
retraite qui avait pris sa pleine
puissance parce que ceux qui avaient
cotisé dans ce système était les
premiers qui prenaient leur retraite
avec une cotisation complète sur ce
système le rapport du corps montre que
dans les prochaines années la part des
pensions dans le PIB va baisser
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas de problème
de financement et pourtant nous voyons
aussi qu'il y a un problème
progressivement un problème de pouvoir
d'achat des retraités de pouvoir d'achat
des retraites c'est ce que dit
l'amendement de nos collègues du groupe
communiste et c'est notre préoccupation
aussi et à partir du moment monsieur le
ministre et messieurs mesdames les
membres de la majorité sénatoriale vous
avez voté des nouvelles exigences qui
sont plus dures
avec un recul de l'âge de la retraite
qui sera plus difficile à à
atteindre pour énormément de de
personnes les pensions vont baisser et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
tirons la sonnette d'alarme en demandant
un rapport pour permettre de trouver une
solution et d'indexer sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur l'évolution du pouvoir
d'achat les pensions
4872 tu as souligne merci monsieur le
président
c'est l'occasion je vais en profiter
pour répondre aussi à des propos
qui ne reflétaient pas la vérité de
Monsieur Retailleau monsieur Arctic 38
alors je voulais dire
si vous voulez si vous voulez
là j'ai été touché au cœur là
Monsieur Retailleau nous a dit que nous
étions dans l'obstruction alors on va
rétablir la vérité
depuis le début nous disons à l'inverse
justement de ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale
que nous voulions discuter de l'article
7 et nous voulions qu'il y a un vote
pour que les Français sachent
qui vote quoi qui est pour la retraite à
64 ans et que personne ne puisse se
cacher de cette responsabilité devant
nos citoyens et donc
nous avons par contre dit qu'on voulait
discuter de l'article 7 nous voulons
qu'il soit voté parce que à l'Assemblée
nationale il n'y a pas eu ce débat et
c'est à ce moment là que vous avez
utilisé tous les artifices tous les
coups brutaux pour empêcher que ce débat
soit serein ça aurait pu être un très
beau débat parce que il concentrait
toute cette réforme et on aurait pu vous
expliquer peut-être vous convaincre même
pourquoi 3 millions et demi de Français
hier on dit non malgré toute votre
propagande
vous avez dit c'est pour les jeunes les
jeunes très majoritairement
les moins de 35 ans disent non à cette
réforme à plus de deux tiers
vous dites que c'est pour l'avenir
tous ceux qui travaillent aujourd'hui
qui sont l'avenir de notre pays qui le
font vivre disent à deux tiers qui sont
contre cette réforme le seul la seule
tranche d'âge la seule tranche d'âge
c'est celle de plus de 65 ans qui ne
sont pas touchés par la peur
amendement 4866 monsieur Kerrouche
merci monsieur le Président nous aurions
pu continuer le jeu des sous amendements
pendant très longtemps
si c'est un jeu c'est exactement un jeu
allez-y
à noter
j'espère que le temps me sera déduit
et donc on les avait les arrêts de jeu
en l'espèce on l'espèce j'espère que
finirait pas comme le PSG en l'espèce
en espèces ici
ce qui s'est simplement passé c'est que
nous voulions dénoncer le coût de force
parlementaire que vous avez fait hier
soir hier soir vous avez fait un coup de
force parlementaire en faisant tomber
des milliers d'amendements en faisant
tomber des amendements qui concernaient
la vie de tous les jours des Français et
nous voulions vous voulions vous montrer
à travers ces sous-amendements et à
travers d'ailleurs ce que nous avions
posé sur celui de Monsieur vorwenberg
que nous pouvions aussi faire comme vous
et nous jeter dans la procédure pour ne
jamais traiter le fond ces amendements
n'avaient pas vocation à être défendue
mais il montre le ridicule de la
situation dans laquelle vous nous avez
mis et j'ai entendu j'ai entendu j'ai
entendu le Président retaillau nous dire
que nous nous radicalisions mais mes
chers collègues mes chers collègues mes
chers collègues
on gardera une seule image de cette
soirée c'est vous qui vous êtes
radicalisé contre les Français et les
Français
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
le président qui va être grandement
favorable par rapport aux propos qu'on
vient d'entendre pour en revenir à la
réalité parce que le sujet sérieux sujet
et sérieux
et il est proposé il est proposé de
revaloriser les pensions sur les
salaires alors qu'actuellement elles
sont sur l'inflation c'est la réforme de
93 qui avait pris cette décision
justement parce qu'il y avait des
problèmes d'équilibre et vous proposez
de revenir à ce qui a déséquilibré donc
4,4 points de PIB ont été nécessaire de
façon supplémentaire à consacrer au
retraites
mais comment vous financez cela comment
vous financez cela par des cotisations
supplémentaires ou
en demandant aux Français de travailler
encore plus c'est bien vers cela que
l'on vous propose avec un plus juste
équilibre avec un plus juste équilibre
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ne faut
pas revenir à cette indexation par
contre faut être attentif les
revalorisations des pensions sont
indexées sur l'inflation encore faut-il
que
à chaque loi de finance soit respecté
cette indexation et qu'il n'y ait pas de
sous indexation monsieur le ministre
comme on a connu il y a quelques années
ça nous paraît tout à fait important
pour le pouvoir d'achat des retraités
maintenant les sous-amendements les sous
amendements ce sont des dates de
revalorisation qui sont fantaisistes
disons le 15 septembre le 1er octobre et
on multiplie les dates et vous auriez
peut-être pu fixé des horaires aussi et
bien vous vous moquez vous vous moquez
des retraités je suis désolé de vous le
dire vous vous moquez des retraités
parce qu'il y a des retraités qui
attendent leur pension et la date de
revalorisation c'est tout à fait
important pour eux et en conséquence
bien entendu on ne peut pas suspecter
ses aidements d'être des amendements
d'obstruction pas du tout c'est pas non
plus se moquer des retraités c'est tout
simplement vouloir se ridiculiser donc à
vie bien sûr défavorable sur l'ensemble
des amendements mais c'est un avis
strictement personnel puisque la
Commission n'a pas eu l'occasion de se
réunir par rapport à ces précieuses
propositions
monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci à Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur l'a dit il y a un instant
là l'indexation des pensions de retraite
sur l'inflation est une décision qui a
été prise en 93 qui a toujours été
maintenu depuis sauf dans des périodes
de désindexation vous l'avez dit puisque
il y a eu des périodes pendant
lesquelles soit l'indexation était
atténuée par rapport au risque au rythme
de l'inflation soit des périodes pendant
lesquelles les dates d'indexation était
modifiées ce qui a amené un certain
nombre de périodes je pense notamment
sur la période 2014 2015 à ce qui est 18
mois et non pas 12 entre une indexation
et la suivante toutes les prestations
sociales à location au minima sont
indexées sur l'inflation c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement souhaite
maintenir l'indexation sur l'inflation
des pensions de retraite je vous
souhaite simplement apporter une
précision puisque dans un certain nombre
d'amendements tel qu'ils étaient rédigés
puisque je n'ai pas et vous je vous prie
de m'en excuser puis assister à la
présentation orale de tous il y avait
une inquiétude ou une évocation
de la pension minimale à 85% du SMIC
pour une carrière complète rémunéré au
niveau du SMIC ce que nous allons
proposer et ce qui viendra dans les
articles suivants c'est de dire que le
minimum contributif qui nous permet
d'atteindre cet objectif de 85 % du SMIC
pour une carrière complète au SMIC sera
indexée sur l'inflation sera d'excès
pardon sur le SPIC pardonnez-moi ce qui
permettra aux assurés ce qui permettra
aux assurer à chaque fois qu'il
demanderont une nouvelle liquidation à
chaque fois qu'un assuré dépendra son
dossier de demande de retraite d'avoir
la garantie que sa première pension pour
les assurer éligibles à la pension
minimale soit égale à 85% du SMIC en
fonction du montant du smic au mois de
la demande une fois cette pension fixée
elle intègrera le régime de toutes les
pensions de retraite c'est-à-dire une
indexation sur l'inflation pour toutes
ces raisons la vie est favorable
bien je vais consulter
explication de vote c'est Monsieur
Kerrou
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur vous nous avez dit que nous
nous étions ridiculisés
c'est votre avis
mais le mien ce soir c'est que vous vous
êtes déshonoré
bien je poursuis par des explications de
vote
et non des appréciations
4874 ceux qui sont pour l'adoption oui
seguet
la main certes un peu tard mais
avec plaisir je le sais c'est pour ça
que je me permets sur les ministres mes
chers collègues on a passé l'article 7
je le dis à monsieur le rapporteur je
pense qu'il faut revenir en débat serein
c'est pas non mais
c'est pas la peine d'avoir de la
provocation comme on a depuis une heure
qui est je vous le dis pour un certain
nombre de mes collègues sur les derniers
amendements j'ai trouvé ça presque
limite je vous le dis monsieur le
rapporteur je pense qu'il faut que tout
le monde se respecte non mais je vous le
dis
non mais bravo donc non non mais que
vous dit qu'on nous disiez que nous
amendements sont farfelus complètement
loufoques au moment où la commission
c'est même pas réuni pour les étudier
je trouve ça presque limite pareil ça
fait depuis hier vous nous disiez vous
nous dites
vous vous en foutez des retraités ou les
travailleurs faire les retraités pauvres
si si ça a été vos mots depuis hier et
vous l'avez dit et vous l'avez utilisé à
plusieurs reprises franchement je vais
vous dire quand ici ça fait 5 ans que je
suis parlementaire quand tous les
groupes de gauche vous ont proposé un
certain nombre de fois d'augmenter les
salaires d'augmenter les pensions de
retraite je pense qu'il faut un peu
d'humidité parce que si vous dites que
nous on veut fabriquer des retraités
pauvres vous vous fabriquez des
travailleuses et des travailleurs
pauvres à la chaîne je vous le dis donc
non mais donc soit
on reprend la Commission se réunir on
étudie les amendements et c'est plus
votre avis personnel c'est la vie de la
Commission on reprend des bastrings
parce que effectivement l'article 7 a
été adopté mais
la loi n'a pas été tout adoptée il reste
très articles et on a encore des
propositions à faire valoir et on va
continuer à débattre et on continue à
rester déterminé à faire échec à ce
projet il y a une mobilisation samedi
prochain on continue
d'autres explications de vote de sauver
l'amendement
3874 double avis défavorable ce qui sont
favorables manifestants devant la main
avis contraire
abstention n'est pas adopté le 4873
c'est le même vote mais je ne veux pas
vous brusquer c'est le même vote le
sous-amendement
serait le même vote c'est
4870 même vote
4868 même vote
4871 même vote et
même vote
4872 même vote et
sous-amendement
4866 même vote je pense oui je pense
bien alors
nous allons examiner maintenant
l'amendement puisque nous avons examiné
les sous amendements il s'agit de
l'amendement
4409 rectifié biche que Madame Cohen
avait présenté
y a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vol
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
de manifeste en levant la main
avec le contraire
il n'est pas adopté mes chers collègues
je vais lever la séance
nous avons examiné 169 abandons au cours
de la journée il en reste
1000 1887 à examiner sur ce texte
notre prochaine séance a lieu jeudi à
10h30 pour la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 la séance élevée je vous souhaite
une excellente nuit